Why you would be >> how you I I went >> I feel like
I'm here to be lectured on. >> Shut up. That's not nice.
You can't talk that way, >> dude. Uh >> why? What?
>> I love watching Adam with somebody who can't tell they're
with them or that he's with them. It's It's just a fun back and
forth. >> What about him when he was gay? Uh like
>> Wait, is Rich Richie Torres is actually >> I approached
him and >> your social universe. You chilled with your
teachers >> or people in the world? behind you. I >> you
were you were >> you hung out with adults. I >> is
Adam keying in on something. An inappropriate relationship perhaps.
Is >> Yeah. Yeah. Um you're pulling behind Donald Trump
right now and uh >> that's not true. >> The Democratic
party has lower approval ratings than do than Donald Trump. >> I
think the story is more complicated >> What is that? >> Yeah.
So, the latest polling from >> Oh, wait. Is it not true
or is it more
The first thing we're starting with today, guys,
is going to be this uh this Adam Adam Freriedeland interview.
Okay, I've been meaning to get to it. I want to get to it now.
I know I know there's some fantastic moments in this. Okay, >> you're
consult >> I know there's some fantastic moments in this.
I don't know if I'm going to watch like the whole thing.
I kind of might want to watch the whole thing. I'm not going
to lie to you. I might want to watch the whole thing. So, he
pulls Richie Torres is in. If you guys don't know who Richie
Torres, Richie Torres is, Richie Torres is the hyper Zionist
New York uh House of Congress member. Okay, that's who Richie
Torres is. He's a bit of a goof. He goes like way over the line
defending Israel all the time. He's like known as the biggest
Zionist in Congress, right?
He's a bit of a goofy guy.
So, I would imagine Adam Freriedeland being, you know, pretty
pro Palestine, pretty I don't know if I'd call him anti-ionist
necessarily, but he's pretty close. I know this interview gets
very good when they go into the last part here,
but I do think that I kind of want to watch some of the other
stuff. So, I'm going to watch the background section. Let's Let's
check this whole thing out. House of Representatives, Richie
Torres. Everyone make some noise.
>> I can't. Hello. >> What's going on? >> Hello.
Well, I got two issues. First of all, you your district is Yankee
Stadium. That is one of your That's one of your >> I represent
Yankee Stadium. Yeah. And I asked you how the Yanks were and
you were like I'm not >> you didn't. >> So I love
the Yankees but I'm not a I'm not a huge baseball fan and I'm
not gonna pretend to be a baseball fan. >> What about the
zoo? >> I love the Bronx. >> Damn. Got to respect
that. Okay. Not going to pretend to be a Yankees fan even though
he's in the district with Yankee Stadium in it. That's brave.
>> Okay. Gardens. >> Do Do you consider the animals
your
>> Uh I consider the Bronx indistinguishable from the United
States Congress. Does that crush in like if you say it to another
guy in Congress? >> It crushes nowhere cuz I you know if
if if I were actually if I had any comedic talent I probably
wouldn't be in >> What do you mean? >> You want to
be a stand up? >> You know when I was a kid I was a fan
not of baseball but professional
>> Attitude era. >> The attitude era. So I started
watching in 1998 Stone Cold Steve Austin. The Rock. I thought
that was golden age.
>> Yeah. So so was I. >> Yeah. That we were watching.
>> Come on. You're not going to talk about Shawn Michaels,
Degeneration X. What are we doing here? >> A huge >> rock
impersonation when I was a kid. Like I was I used to >> I
like knew of you as a congressman, but I didn't know your backstory
and uh I mean, god damn. Wow. I mean, it's an incredibly uh inspirational
story that you have. >> And unlike Joy Santos, I have a
true >> that you that's your op. >> I have I have
no Only Fans account, but I do have a actual B. >> Did
he have an Only Fans? >> Oh, yeah. >> In Congress.
I'm not sure if he had it, but certainly it was generating income.
>> You would have been the first. I mean, >> who
knows? I mean, I'm not closely following closely following the
only fans accounts of every member of >> Can't stand this
guy. >> No, just, you know, just I want to >> Do
you miss him? Pretty funny. >> Dude represents the brokeest
people in the country and all he does is blow Israel. The brokeest
people in the country are in New York City.
That seems impossible. Is his district like somehow exclusively
homeless people? How in the world could it be the It's the hood.
Yankee Stadium in the hood. Really?
It's the Bronx? Yeah, but lots of the Bronx is like reclaimed
and uh Oh, what do you call it when you go and you uh you remake
the Bronx into like a high
>> I thought the Bronx was largely like reclaimed and um
what is it called? Gentrified. Yeah, gentrified. I thought they
gentrified the [__] out of the Bronx.
Am I crazy? It's not. I should ask. I I listen other people would
know. I've never been to New York. Okay. Bronx is the worst district.
NY heavily gang area. Yeah, I have no doubt that it's the worst
in New York City, but like
you tell me that that like the Bronx is lower income than like
the projects in Baltimore,
that seems impossible to me. But okay, >> you know, he
was uh he was a source of comedic enjoyment. Yeah, >> his
tweet right before jail was amazing. He's like, "The curtain
closes like that." You know, she walks off stage. He he was a
he was a real ham, George. >> Yeah, he was. >> But
he was a you he was a complete fraud, right? >> Uh total
fraud. Yeah. >> Yeah. Because he he bought like Birkin
bags with >> I got my hair braided in the Bronx once and
I never went back. Okay. All right. >> Campaign funds.
>> Well, also he fabricated every aspect of his biography.
It was not like he told one lie here or there. It was like the
whole story was a complete fabrication. I feel like in in this
day and age that's kind of like uh that's part that's that's
in play. I feel like you can do it. >> No, it's it's I've
never >> I feel like it's such a chaotic time like Yeah.
Like I I went to Harvard Law School and I I I used to be the
the coolest guy in my school and I'm I'm also Brazilian and what
did he say? >> No, he said that his you know he had his
his parents were Holocaust survivors
Ukrainian because of the war in Ukraine. He was also Ukrainian
>> and he had, you know, he was friends who died in the
mash in Orlando. >> He's amazing. >> He like incorporated
every
>> hard to not love the story of George Santos in retrospect,
right? Once he's no longer in power, it's like, dude, that that's
insane that that happened >> current event into his life
story. >> Pathological liars are great, but he he took
it all the way to the the freaking the to the show. Although
I, you know, he inspired me to introduce a bill that has, I think
it's the greatest acronym in the history of of congressional,
the Santos Act. >> And what was it? >> Stop another
non-truthful office seeker. >> Am I sensing that there's
like >> Santos Act? >> That the two of you guys as
like young New York gay uh like Latino. >> Wait, wait,
is Rich Richie Torres is actually gay? I actually need to know.
>> Congressman, he's naturally like your foil. He's your
Darth Vader.
>> Let's assume like after he was expelled from Congress,
I became the most
>> gay Latino congressman from New York. How's that? >> You're
No, I'm
>> Oh, come on. I wouldn't wish this upon my greatest enemy.
You don't want that. You don't want any part of this, my >> You
never heard this comment. He's not. >> Yeah, I've heard
a lot of people say that, but you don't. I'm just >> No,
he invented the term >> about you. I don't >> He
invented the term about himself. >> It's just a word with
it. Yeah. I love watching Adam with somebody who can't tell they're
[__] with him or that he's with them. It's It's just
a fun back and forth. When he was confronted, you know, why did
you lie about being You said I never said I was. I said I >> I
would say that I'm uh that I'm I'm >> But you're actually
>> Yeah. Unfortunately. Yeah. Yeah. It's tough. Yeah. I
can't quit. No. >> I wrote a >> I think he can't
tell right now. I think he can't tell right now. I think he >> letter
to BB and they reject. They don't let you out. It's like the
mafia. You know that.
>> You know how you join is when you're a >> Yeah.
you your parents have a party and then this like old wizard walks
in and then he pulls your your uh your diaper off. Yeah. And
then your whole family looks at your beautiful baby and then
he cuts the the part that I I guess gives one pleasure later
on in life and during and uh and then there's like a deli tray
there and stuff. >> That's that's how you join the club.
>> But we've been doing it for a while though. I don't
know. I don't mind it. You you really didn't like my humor. I
mean, you've endured for thousands of years, so something's going
right. >> We're Yeah. Yeah, >> dude. This guy This
guy's ready to glaze any he meets. Okay. Doesn't even matter
if they're anti-ionist. He's just ready to glaze. >> I
guess so. It's the It's definitely the wizard and the baby's
part. >> Yeah. Well, >> I know. I'm I'm being crude
with a member of the of the legis. >> These are important
decisions that parents have to What's rude is that we're in a
in an era where like uh talking to someone in the legislative
uh branch is uh it's a it's a a privilege because it's so crazy.
Uh and uh >> the privilege is mine. You're the one with
the massive following audience. You were in the New Yorker. You
know I know that cuz you told me >> not because I read
the profile. You told me you were in the New Yorker. So congratulations
on the profile. You know you would be considered young in the
United States Congress. >> Yeah. I mean, I'm I've only
been able to >> My dating profile says I'm congressionally
young. >> Congressionally young >> and congressionally
attractive just in case you're disappointed. >> That gets
that gets some action. >> Is it a plus? Uh, it's not clear.
It's not clear. >> It has to be. >> I mean, I work
7 days a week, so that has a crowding out effect. But >> yeah,
and you're with the worst people on earth. >> what you
what are you doing to yourself? It's it's must be tough. >> Yeah.
One of my colleagues said to me that Congress is the best university
in the world. >> Really? And because you just have access
to some of the brightest minds, you can learn a tremendous amount.
>> you can't do the congressionally attractive and then
say, "Oh, it's the brightest minds." At the same time, come on,
guys. >> Some of Yeah. Yeah. >> We certainly have
access to >> It's like the Sorbon or something in Congress.
How boring is it like to be in the government sometimes? What's
the most boring part of it? >> I mean, I love it. >> You
love it >> because of the variety. >> You like parliamentary
procedure and stuff like I feel like no position has more variety
than a house member cuz one >> you get to be local, state,
national, and international at the same time. So one day I'm
receiving a pothole, a complaint about a pothole on form road.
>> This is a canned line that he's I guarantee you you
go through this guy's like last 10 interviews and he says this
line in every single one of them. It's it's just the variety,
man. It's like, you know, local, state, national, international.
One day you're fixing a pothole down in Main Street. The next
day you're talking to some diplomat from Russia, okay, about
ending the war in >> or pressuring the mayor to crack down
on an open air drug market in the South Bronx. And the next day
>> in Congress about that >> and then the next I'm
receiving like a briefing from the CIA about rising tensions
between the >> That's a fantastic point, Adam. Yeah. At
what point in in Congress do they come to you about a pothole
in New York? Are you talking about the >> United States
and China? What do you do about the pothole in DC though? I'm
just >> I mean I I use my platform to pressure the mayor
to solve problems or the >> Adams. Yeah. Let me Can I guess
who you were in school growing up? >> You were like a you
were you student
>> Uh no, not student government. >> You were like
a debate club or >> I was the captain of the law team.
>> Law team. >> Oh, so you wanted to be a lawyer?
>> Yeah, I had dreams of becoming either a lawyer or a
teacher. >> So you did mock trial, right? I did moo court
and mock trial but I was the ma I was a like a master court.
>> And what did you like? You liked like the Attakus Finch
style like closing >> So that's more that was mock trial.
Moo court is modeled after the Supreme Court or an appella court.
So you deliver an argument before a panel of judges >> who
would interrupt you with questions. >> Speeches. The one
that's less c like uh >> No, because it teaches you to
think on your feet. >> Yeah. It's less It's less theatrical.
>> So So but that was your prep for the >> You went
to the show. It was the first time when I discovered I had a
talent for public speaking or I thought I had a talent for talking.
>> Early on, you grew up in a single mother home. You have
a twin brother. >> This guy is like trying so hard to restrain
how awesome he thinks he is. You guys picking this up that like
he knows he shouldn't be talking about how awesome he is, but
he loves himself like completely. Like everything oozing out
of him is like he is he's ready to say he's awesome, but he's
like holding it back. Oh, you know, this is the first time I
found out I have talent for public speaking. Or I, you know,
think I do. Huh? Congress. I love Congress because it's all the
brightest minds. Or, you know, we have access to the brightest
minds.
>> He's biologically older. I'm temperamentally older.
>> Identical or no? >> Fraternal. We're fake twins.
>> That's all right. >> 5 minutes apart. >> I
was on a date once with a girl who told me the first date. She
said, "I have an identical twin." I was I can't do it. How? I
can't tell her secrets. >> She has her brain is connected
to some other another one of her. Yeah, >> you can't trust
these people. >> It's funny. When I was a kid, >> that's
a prejudice of mine. >> People would ask me, "Where's your
brother?" I'm like, "We're we're fraternal twins, not Siamese
twins." Like, I don't know his whereabouts at every moment. So,
>> but you're good at DC, >> dude. Siamese I mean,
if what if you were separated? Siamese twins don't have like
an actual psychic connection. Siamese if they're if you're Siamese
twins, they wouldn't be asking where's your brother. Your brother
would be connected to you, >> I'm learning, DC. >> You're
still learning? >> Yeah, of course. I've only been there
for three terms.
It's the most complicated legislature on >> Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. I'm still learning. I've only been there for
12 years. I need at least 12 more. Okay, guys. Vote Torres. >> No
one's going to master it in three terms. I think the problem
with DC is not that it's corrupt. >> Oh, that counts as
Oh,
wait. Is that is the Oh, how does it work with Congress people?
Do they serve three terms or do they serve four terms? House
terms are two years. So, do they they only serve two or do they
s like I realize they can serve consecutively, but when you're
elected, are you elected for three terms or two terms? So, you
Yeah, I realize unlimited terms, but are you up in every single
midterm? In every single midterm, you're up every single time
when you're in the House. Oh, so you do every two years? I didn't
know that. I for some reason I thought they offset some of the
seats so that you'd elect like half of them um in the midterms
or whatever and half of them in the That's crazy. Uh, I don't
know why I didn't know that. That's a really weird thing to not
know. It seems like really important. It's in in the Senate of
six years. All right.
Okay. All right. I got it. Yeah, that's weird that I I just didn't
know that. That's like a pretty important thing to care about
American politics and not know. I feel a little silly for not
knowing that. I like I I know quite a bit about American politics
for somebody who's not from that country. And that seems like
a really important thing that I didn't actually know. >> The
problem with DC is that it's stupid. There's just so much absurdity
in DC. >> I thought you said it's the smartest places in
the world. >> Well, can you have access to some of the
brightest minds? So like if you if you want to learn more about
artificial intelligence or quantum computing or >> you
can reach out to some of the best minds. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> The breast mind right now. >> But call Zuck
right now. >> People generally will take your call. I'm
not calling now. So >> you I don't know. I don't know.
>> Your boys was up. You said I'm not calling him now.
You have his number. >> Well, I don't know. So, what CEO
is your best friend? What's >> mention who's my best friend?
>> Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait. Adam does this every episode,
right? This is a bit Adam does. >> He He like asks who
people know and he's like, "Call them. Call him right now." He
did this to Hassan, right? Didn't he try to get Hassan to call
Mr. Beast? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> How many CEO
friends do you have? >> I don't have many CEO friends.
>> Well, you said you call anyone on the phone at any time.
>> If I If I If I had a question about >> I'm not
as big a fan of Mati policy, I probably could get a meeting with
a CEO. Yeah, that's true of any member of >> Yeah. Did
you grow up in the district you represent? >> Uh my father's
from this from M Haven. I'm from Thragneck Houses. So I grew
up in a public housing development in Thrageneck Houses right
across the street from what was formerly Trump Golf >> And
I kid you not, as the golf course was undergoing construction,
it unleashed a skunk infestation. So I tell
>> So I tell people I've been smelling the stench of Donald
Trump long before he became president that they were it was infested
with skunks. Dude, >> what's the like >> the canned
lines I think do we have any room left for like canned lines
like just totally canned stories anymore or is it time like I
feel like entertainment wise young people have moved to entertainers
that are not like scripted. It's like a lot of on the-fly entertainment
like streaming and I I be just streaming, right? I feel like
streaming's taken off because people like stuff that's less scripted.
I feel like we're slowly moving away from like all totally scripted,
totally bull interactions.
I wonder when that'll flow up to politicians. I mean, you could
argue it did with Trump cuz I don't know if you could argue anything
Trump does is scripted, but it's not really trickled down to
anyone else. Never. You think never green pepper? I don't know.
It does feel like it's stalled a little bit that it's kind of
gone back. It's kind of gone back in a little more in the scripted
direction, too. So, yeah, maybe not. >> Like, you grew
up in New York City, so born and raised in the Bronx. Our president
is an outer burough New Yorker >> Yeah. From Queens. >> Right.
He he wants to present that he's a that he's like Mr. like Goldman
Sachs, but really he's a New York City real estate guy. Is that
correct? Yeah. >> He was never respected in the real estate
industry. He was known to like rip off his contractors and he
was seen as a joke within the industry. >> Yeah. He he
figured out that if you keep someone in a lawuit
known for his self-promotion and >> than he was for his
actual effectiveness in real estate. >> Yeah. Have you
ever What? >> I mean, you can say that
you can say that about Trump, but like the real estate properties
he has are massive and like massively valuable, right? Who knows
how much he owns of them anymore, but like the property he has
is insanely valuable. I think I think some of his New York real
estate is like like a couple of those buildings are hundreds
of millions each. No. >> What have your interactions been
with the president? >> No interactions. Never met him.
Have no desire to meet him. >> Let's practice it right
now. feel like he's the worst person on earth. >> You don't
want to meet him once. You're in the government, though. You
You got to be the president. >> He's the devil. >> He's
the devil. >> You got to say, you got to have a good burn
for the for the president.
>> How? Wait, how do you how do you meet Richie Torres?
You're the most pro-Israel member of Congress or one of the most
pro-Israel member members of Congress. And you say Donald Trump
is the devil. Donald Trump's is BB Netanyahu's best buddy.
What do you mean Donald Trump's the devil? Does that mean BB's
evil, too?
Adam, you got to hit him with this one. If Trump's the devil,
he's best friends with BB. His His son-in-law is best friends
with BB. They're the closest family to BB Netanyahu in the world.
Are you saying BB might be friends with evil people?
>> I'm the I'm Trump. >> What's up? I'm Trump.
>> Nice to meet you. >> That's your No, you you just
bombed.
>> You can't like that with some weird >> I'm going
to shake Donald Trump's hand. Yeah, you have to say like um you're
you've you're
doing like the >> What happened? Okay, I'm going to sound
like a boomer here. What happened to just like having enough
respect for the office of the president or prime minister in
my case that you just like you feel like a difference to that
office, you want to shake the hand of the person who's in that
office no matter what, right? >> Like the Holocaust right
now in this country like you're >> okay. Maybe I'd understand
not wanting to shake Trump's hand, but it's like the president.
I don't know. I think that should be special
even if it's Destiny. Well, not for me, but like for most people,
you don't have a personal relationship. It's not like this guy's
got a personal relationship, right? >> You have to say
like you're ruining this country right now. >> Like seriously,
why don't you say something like that? You're that you said the
>> people People People did this in my country with Trudeau,
Porter Beller. With any president before Trump, I would. They're
like, "Oh, I hate I hate Trudeau so much." And it's like, I get
that you don't like him, but you should have respect for the
office of the prime minister. Okay? You should have respect for
the office of the head of state no matter what in my opinion.
And like Trudeau was nowhere near as bad as Trump. I just I thought
it was I thought it was gross in my country. Maybe I you know
I'm not American so maybe with Trump it's like worse. Okay. But
Trudeau
in true fashion perhaps he just brought in the people who did
the Okay.
Sorry I'm reading a Porter Bellar comment. Trudeau wasn't trying
to everything about your country though was he? No, I don't think
he was. He's not quite the same. He is not quite the >> Okay,
we we'll practice. Okay. >> Okay. Go ahead. >> Let's
get it. Let's Come on, dude. >> Mr. President. >> How
are you? >> I'm looking forward Hopefully, you can release
those files.
>> I need to learn the Indian cast system. Okay. Cuz like
I'm pretty sure most of the people I would have known in Canada
who are Indian Canadians, they'd be like higher cast, right?
If I could just be appropriately like cast aware and racist to
like the lower cast that Canada was bringing in on mass then
then my racism might actually be wellreceived by my Indian friends.
It's like look at this Brahman type. Look at this Brahmin loser,
right? But I'm not I'm not cast aare. I'm class aware. I'm not
cast aware. Brahman are the top guys. Look at these non Brahman
ass losers. Okay. >> Epstein. That's your No, come on,
dude. That first of all, you guys already lost on Epste. >> You
think we lost on Epste? He's obviously in the finals. >> Well,
half of the Files is your guys, too, right? So, you know, but
half the files is your guys, too. So, that's why you guys didn't
do this. My my view is release the files and let the dice pull
what they make. >> You guys lost on Epcene. >> Why
do we lose? >> His crappy excuse like everyone uh his whole
base doesn't really care. >> Yeah, they moved on. >> What
we found is that they actually don't care. Maggot didn't really
care. >> Yeah, you guys really are having a rough one right
now. >> I think what's your advice for us? >> Um
I don't know. I mean, you're the you're in you're one of the
guys, so uh I'll tell you what I I'm seeing, right? >> Please
tell me that. I really wanted to give you your whole story about
where >> you want me to tell my story. >> No, no,
no. Cuz I I want to talk about this, but
>> you clearly don't want to hear my >> I've been
trying to toss it to your story, which that's a Hallmark movie.
>> We'd open this up like this guy's You're the first uh
black uh gay guy to be in the government. Gay guy. Gay man to
be in the government. Gay guys. We You can't say >> um
Well, you just forgetting. We just We just pretending Barack
Obama
doesn't exist now. that really
uh >> first you're the first >> Latino and black
gay member of Congress. >> First Latino United States.
Yeah, >> it doesn't roll off the tongue that one. >> Too
many ident. >> Never mind. Obama's not Latino. >> Yeah.
Yeah. First black. >> It's a joke. It's a joke about Michelle
Obama being gay. Okay. Being a not gay. Michelle Obama being
a man. It's a joke about Michelle Obama being a man. Okay. >> President
Obama.
Come on. >> Yeah. First Latino and black. Once you have
a first black president, everything else becomes less impressive.
>> How many uh LGBT members of the of Congress are there?
>> There are quite a few. Like more than >> More
than 10. >> And there's
>> we're we're going to need a gaylasian.
Okay. Until we have a gay blazion in Congress, America won't
be healed. We need that more than anything. >> 100 uh Senate.
How many house?
>> So 535 in total. >> Are there any? No. Republicans,
right, >> who are openly LGBTQ. >> Oh, you're saying
none of them. >> You're spilling the tea right now. >> Well,
what my my running joke is the LGBTQ caucus is the only caucus
that can expand without winning an election. We just have to
take members out of the >> Would you do that as you were
in the closet your life, right? Like what >> would you
do that? Would you out other gay members of Congress? >> What
are the ethics there? It's really interesting cuz like >> would
I outnumber? No. >> If you see a closet gay Republican
like advocating for something that
>> you you think this guy is really against gay marriage,
here's a picture of me sucking his dick from last night. It's
over. It's over. Lindsey Graham. Okay. You've been outed. >> Is
would I out him? >> Well, it's it's advocate for like taking
away gay marriage or something like >> I said it before
you did, Rhynox. I said it before you did. We all know Lindsey
Graham is gay. Okay. What what's the rule there? Because you
were in the closet yourself as a young man and it's a painful
thing, I would imagine.
>> Yeah. No, you have to go through the Yeah, it's a process.
>> You found out in middle school? >> Wait, hold
on. No way.
Wait. No way. Hold on. Didn't I point this out? No, no, no, no,
no. Didn't I point this out that got this like weird highlighted
streak that he adds to his hair? I like a hairdresser and she
pointed this streak out when his hair was longer. Queen clearly
got a haircut. Okay. >> No, no, no, no. >> He's he
said on stream today it's graying.
The pigment's going away. >> It's not graying. He gets
that highlight put in. No. >> No. Yeah.
>> That's not graying. Come on. No way. No way. There's
no way that's There's no way that's graying. Come on.
Really? That would be crazy if he's just like if he was like
totally gray by the end of the year. Okay. by the end of 2026
and he still looks like 12 with like this totally gray hair.
That'd be nuts. He's got to get a tan, right? I think we got
to pay for Queenman tanning sessions. If he goes gray, he can't
be gray and pale at the same time. I don't think that's allowed.
I think he's got to get or we get him like the Donald Trump spray
tanning thing, right? We fund raise. I think so. I think so.
Oh, guys, there's a blastoff tweet pinned in the chat. Interact
with the blast off tweet. Like the blastoff tweet. Retweet the
blastoff tweet. Okay. There's a blastoff tweet. It's there. Let's
go. Let's go. Dude, I had a fight with Connor before the stream
today and it was just so stupid.
H. It was so stupid. Do I I might pause for a quick second and
just go over it to be honest. I'll just go over for a quick sec.
It's so dumb.
He tweets this me trying to stop the doc war through Christian
ethics. I got shot in the chest. Bro,
there's no doc war. There's like honest to God and maybe this
makes a lot of sense. Maybe it actually fits their side quite
well, but it's like we are like innocent Palestinians and let's
say uh let's say in this case KF's like we're just like running
a shop over here and we're getting targeted, okay, with [__]
drone strikes for no [__]
We didn't do [__] Yeah, we're in Gaza, but we didn't
do [__] And then he's like, okay, so I I had to quote
tweet this. All right. And to quote tweet this and just like,
"Bro, you giggled along." Destiny's like, "I need Doobie's docs
immediately." And Connor's like, "I disavow. Doobie, I disavow."
Also, Destiny, what did Doobie do to you? And then there's just
no answer. It's literally like I analogized it. Yeah, this is
the problem. You analogized it to Russia Ukraine and Connor's
Connor was like, "It's not a war." And it's like, "No, but we're
talking about the morality of like initiating conflicts."
That's that's the comparison, Connor, that you can't just make
up some like your Ukraine and just do whatever you want. The
underlying reality matters. Uh and Connor is just paying penance
for all the minorities you shot as a mall. What? No, no, no.
But he's like, his his response to me is, "How about you all
shut the [__] up and leave each other alone, including
Steven?" Oh, thanks for the clarification. Including Steven.
Brother, I was I was down to only covering this guy's court docs
when they dropped. That's all I covered about him for like weeks
and weeks and weeks. That was like all I was covering, just those
court docs. And then he keeps upping it, upping the Annie for
no reason. Uh but also, this is just an insane thing to say when
one one person's openly trying to dox anyone anyone who says
something bad about him. Okay, that's the line. By the way, the
Doobie stuff, we read the Doobie comments. Dubbie is basically
like, I don't I don't like this guy. I don't like this guy at
all. No, but Destiny has doxed people and he's trying to dox
people and he's calling for people to get killed and right all
this and Conor's like, "Stop being" and I'm like, "Yeah, this
guy's lying about uh lying about this." Let's say from today,
this guy's lying about having he's just lying about what those
logs say. I say he's lying and his response is, "I'm going to
dox people around you." It's like disproportionate. Anyway, Kilo
had a good tweet here. Side A criticizes side B for morally objectionable
behavior and using his platform to silence, intimidate, and harass
side A uses his platform to side B uses his platform to silence,
intimidate, and harass side A. Leave each other alone. This is
this is a good thread right here. The contention is they're both
doing it. Chase and Queen say they don't, but they've also made
endless Alog content about it. Yes, we've commented on how this
guy's a Yes, if Destiny wanted to comment on how we're we'd be
totally fine. That's That's the game, brother. That's the game.
We're all We're totally down with that. We're totally fine with
that,
right? That's that's just the game and we're all good with it.
Kilo responds, "How is making content about an allegation on
par with the allegation itself? You're working towards a a precedent
where people who criticize someone are for doxing are doing the
moral equivalent of doxing. Laauo." Uh Connor says, "The case
has been made a million times. We all heard you. We understand.
Mission accomplished. The war is over. Go home." So because they're
which is just really funny to me because clearly the case hasn't
been made. A bunch of people still want to try to say that this
guy is a useful person in politics when he is objectively talking
and requesting Dubbies Docs on a stream with Connor live showing
that he has no respect for Conor's boundaries, no respect for
Conor's principles, right? Ask for Dubbies Docs live says he
will release that as soon as it's given to him. Right? Same way
he's done with me and Quebin, right? calling for it from his
audience saying you will release it immediately if he gets it.
Essentially just being bad empanada. He's trying to dox him live
today. That's crazy. All right.
And it's like the case has been made. No, Connor, the case hasn't
been made because you still go on there, have him call for somebody's
docs in front of you, right? And you basically just go, I disavow
that. And you keep talking to him and laughing along. And it's
like, why won't you just leave Destiny alone? cuz he's still
trying to dox anybody who has a negative opinion of him. By the
way, all he does when he does that is he just pushes like Dooby
interacts a little bit with people in my server now. Of course
he does, though, cuz he's starting to realize, oh, this Destiny
guy is actually quite bad. Quite a bit worse than I thought.
Okay, hold on a second. All right. All right. All right. Uh,
so let's keep just keep reading this. So, because their position
has already been made clear once they shouldn't continue to cover
the story despite new information, evidence, and developments
coming out that is likely interesting to their viewers. I'm not
even saying that. cover it. Stop with the personal invective
in praying on someone's downfall and then when that energy comes
back, bro, I've never participated in any of the Destiny or KF
does, okay? I've never docked somebody. I don't do any of that.
I keep his like uh like people he's dating. I keep I keep all
these people like out of it as far as my personal opinion goes.
I don't even reference uh all of this with his kit. I've avoided
all of that. Right. What is Destiny held back while I do all
of that?
while I maintain some level of principle when I go to cover him.
Nothing. He doesn't hold anything back. He'll throw everything
at the wall, right? This guy shows up in my chat four times a
week to try to mock uh somebody he used to claim he liked, right?
Because they they had like a sad post on Twitter a couple weeks
ago. Does he only withholds consent? I don't know if that's necessarily
makes sense, Pumpernickel, but thank you for the comment. All
right. Uh the way you talk about this topic is incredible. You're
able to magically convince yourself that there's an equal push
and pull on both sides. Even people negatively covering somebody
they dislike, being insulting, etc. is somehow just getting that
energy back when they get doxed and threatened IRL. I do not
believe you would hold this standard for literally anybody else.
Destiny did this to Dubbie. When has Dubbie covered Destiny's
allegations on stream extensively? Steven's argument is that
he's being doxed and swatted actively for the past year. How
is that not reciprocal if he believes these people are involved
are the involved parties? Connor is honestly doing honest to
God doing the well Trump thought he won the election so like
is he really that bad when he tries to overthrow it? Like he
thought he won. He really thought he won. He really thought he
won, guys. Is he actually doing something bad if he tries to
overthrow the peaceful transfer of power? He thought he won.
The material like like literally Connor is arguing against all
of the stated preferences and principles he has, right? He knows
that you have to be able to prove that that you have to be able
to actually show something, but he doesn't care.
Well, he really thinks that that's happening. So, of course,
he's going to do that. my schizophrenic friend is going to you
if he thinks you're working against him and if you uh if you
if you walk within you know 100 feet of us he thinks you're working
against him and he's going to you's also arguing against the
actual timeline of events he is yes in many ways BPD uh that
is the argument DS is going with but obviously we don't condone
that so don't do it chat BPD said if I say Connor is doxing me
can I just dox him no because we're not uh even if Connor decides
that this standard is good enough for him which is insane
Uh, we don't support that standard at all. Okay.
Feels like you're saying something you believe in, but pretending
it's someone else saying it, so you're not held held responsible
for it. You either agree with him, in which case it's your position,
or you don't think that, in which case you should think he's
wrong.
Did Connor respond? I don't know. I don't dox. I don't do then.
So, so this this right here, I don't know. Connor responds to
Kilo after Kilo makes a great point. Connor says, I don't know.
I don't dox. I don't do gay ops. I don't research this stuff.
I think it's gay. Then shut the up.
Don't say both sides need to stop. If you're going to later go
to, oh, I don't know what's going on, guys. I don't really look
any of this stuff up. I don't really know what's happening here,
guys. I have no idea what's going on over here. It's like, oh,
thank you. Thank you, dude. It's It's crazy, right? Like, just
shut the up, dude. That's Anyway, Kayo is pretty good at running
this down from like a uh what do you call it? like a first principal's
basis a lot of the time. So, Connor Connor started arguing with
him and I just went live. All right. So, I didn't even read these
tweets yet. Just to clarify, you're currently publicly defending
somebody who is accused of morally morally objectionable things,
who threatens to dox and kill people who talk about him a little
too much online. And when pressed, you say maybe he thinks they're
responsible for the same sets of behaviors. And when I ask you
if you agree with that, because it would be worthless to say
if you didn't, uh, you say, "I don't know. I think all this stuff,
this stuff is all gay." Why are you talking about this again?
I criticized Steven's behavior to his face yesterday. If you
don't know that, why are you talking about this? You could have
assaulted him and spat on his unconscious body and it doesn't
change the content of this thread. Okay, I think for the third
time, I think you have autism. Like, like Kila just won
Just totally won.
Somewhere in this thread, Connor tells me that I don't care about
the victims at all. I don't understand how he gets there, right?
I don't think I don't understand how he gets there at all. Let's
see here.
Stop being out. Where do I respond further to this? I don't know
where I responded further to this. Anyway, that's probably enough,
Connor. Okay. I I just don't understand. Like, dude, you're arguing
this. You keep arguing it over and over and over again. And then
when you're pressed and you have to actually say like you have
to nut up or shut up, you go, "Oh, I don't know anything about
this. This is pretty gay, guys." Then why make that first post?
Why Why make the first post? Why talk? Why open your mouth, brother?
for reals. For reals, brother. Anyway,
anyway, that was uh that was the Twitter stuff real quick. I
don't know why I don't know what set me off there. You guys were
talking about it in the side. Okay, we're back to Richie Torres.
We're watch this interview and then maybe I'm thinking about
doing the Destiny stuff after this. We could cover that response
real quick and then Yeah, we'll see where we're going. >> I
realized that I was in middle school. >> All right. >> When
was it? Titanic Leo DiCaprio. No, >> I didn't realize at
all when I was Leonardo DiCaprio. >> What? How was it?
What was it? Can you get him to come on stream and argue?
>> maybe, maybe. >> I forget exactly how I realize,
but >> you forgot. No, you don't forget. >> You got
to have a better story. You're a politician. Titanic Leonardo.
>> I'm not often asked about my coming out story in the
Bronx. So, >> why not? It's an interesting story, >> And
like you're you're Puerto Rican. Was you were afraid of uh experiencing
homophobia in your community or >> Yeah, I grew up in the
project, so it's a machismo environment. >> And what about
in your family? Was there a like when did you come out to then?
>> And was that when you came out? Uh, >> no. Then
then I came out graduated over time and then when I ran for office
when I was 24, I decided to be out to everyone to run as an openly
LGBTQ
>> But that was back in 200. >> When you were at
school and stuff, you didn't tell people that you were gay or
>> Yeah, I was telling more and more people over time.
>> I thought you were at an assembly or >> Yes, I
was at a debate competition where I said I was a gayr. So that's
coming >> Isn't that like a Jim McGrevy moment though?
Remember he said I as a gay >> he gave the speech and that's
such a >> You're a kid coming out of the closet. Don't
diminish that experience. >> Yeah, it was back in >> No,
that's your story. Why Why would you say that that was just a
debate competition? It has to be scary. >> I agree. It
was terrifying. >> What led you to do it at debate? >> Yeah.
I don't know. It felt It just felt You know, it's interesting.
>> Did you see something that you were like >> Yes.
I was I was browsing through >> and I ran into the profile
of of a >> Uhhuh. who who identified as gay and it was
the first time I I knew of a person in my social universe who
was openly LGBTQ and so I approached him and >> your social
universe you chilled with your teachers >> or people in
the world I knew I guess >> you were you were >> you
hung out with adults I >> is Adam keying in on something
an inappropriate relationship perhaps is >> yeah so it's
the first adult >> Adam Adam is you know Adam's a man sitting
in like a chair right now okay I get the feeling that He's able
to identify trauma with like the uh the precision of a hawk.
All right. He's like zoning in on this right now. Oh, you hung
out with this teacher who was openly gay. Is the first person
you knew who was openly gay? Oh, tell me more about that. Tell
me more about that. >> Well, or a person that was openly
gay. >> Yeah. In my Yeah, cuz I grew up in a world where
no one was openly gay. >> You hung out with this guy and
um uh I just spontaneously came out. It was the first time I
ever had acknowledge myself to someone. >> Do you feel
like um share your story like and uh make it all the way to Congress?
So that has to be an inspiration of people that grew up in a
place like that. No, >> that must feel good. No, >> it
does. >> So why you diminishing it on the >> diminishing
it, but I I feel >> you should be proud of that. I was
in the New Yorker yesterday. You were >> I was in the New
Yorker as well back in >> Oh, okay. I was yesterday. So
both both of us are probably the same same uh >> Yeah.
But you're you're at a much higher level than I am. So >> no,
you were uh 2016. You were a birdie dog again. >> I was
2016. >> So wait, so go back to that cuz it's it's interesting
to me. So, like you had this mental health crisis in college,
>> And uh did it stem it stemmed from being gay? Is that
what it was? >> Uh not only from my But why is Adam helping
ops write his attack ads? Well, Richie Torres is like kind of
bordering on disgustingly Zionist, right? Like like pretty insanely
Zionist. Like
I'll defend Israel's right to do anything, right?
I could see why Adam would help. >> mean, I had a identity,
but I had a severe struggle with depression. Yeah. >> Which
began in high school. >> But then became worse in college
and I dropped out of college
and at some point even thought of committing.
>> Underwent hospitalization. Felt as if the world around
me had collapsed. Um but then I began like taking an anti-depressant
going through psychotherapy and it just gave me a fighting chance
to rebuild my life. So
>> a few years of hospitalization, I rebuild my life and
became the youngest elected official in America's largest city.
I ran for the council and then ultimately ran for the United
States Congress and here I am. >> And it was a few years
that you you were going through that. >> And so and what
did you do once you got out? What what how did you restart your
>> Well, instead of going back to school, I went into politics.
So I was a >> housing organizing
>> for New York City council and then I ran for public
office myself. >> I would have moved to like France or
>> I couldn't I couldn't afford to move to France. I grew
up poor. >> You can figure it out. >> You get a ticket,
you get to France, I don't know. Busk, do you know a guitar?
>> He did a guitar and put the the >> Is that Is
that Oh, no. He was doing guitar. Never mind. I thought he like
pulled out a violin or something was saying that was guitar.
>> Obviously to run for office. >> I misunderstood.
>> You have to have a call to public service. You guys
all say that. But like you have to have a ambition like as well,
right? That has to be part of it, right? Like I want to do >> I
think an ambition to make a difference. Yeah. >> Yeah.
But you you want to be I want to be the president of the United,
you know? Come on. >> I have no desire to be president.
>> Is your ambition purely just to make a a difference?
I mean, it's a very abstract term to what's your dream, you know?
>> My goal is to be the best elected official I can be.
>> And then let the rest take care of >> Yeah. That
doesn't work for me. >> Works for me. >> You could
say like I I want to like I want to make sure that >> I
mean, I would love to be >> say a better thing like I want
to make sure that kids in my neighborhood could like, you know,
have a better life or something. Saying the best that you could
be is so abstract. You could you could vote for anything. >> I
mean, I can tell you why I ran into public office. So, >> which
is what? >> Uh it was really about public housing. So So,
you know, born and raised in the Bronx, spent most of my life
in poverty. >> Uhhuh. and raised by a single mother. He
raised three of us on a minimum wage which in the 1990s was $4.25
an hour. >> But the most formative experience of my life
was growing up in public housing. And in New York City, there's
an institution known as the New York City Housing Authority,
NICHA, >> which manages the largest stock of public housing
in the country. It houses about a half a million people. >> And
it's been so chronically underfunded by the federal government
that it has a capital need of $80 billion in county. >> And
and is that issue something that affects your constituents? Because
you represent the poorest district. one of the largest concentrations
of public housing in the country. >> And so you have like
asthmatics who are struggling to breathe in their homes. >> You
live in unsafe circumstances as well, right? >> I mean,
I grew up without heat and hot >> Um molded conditions,
leaking
>> like these conditions, you know, there's the living
conditions of public housing have become a humanitarian crisis.
>> Okay, this is all like cool. I want to hear what he
did about public housing. And uh >> I think I think you
know if if if NICHA were a city unto itself, it would be the
largest city of low-income black and brown Americans in the United
States and it's the forgotten city of New York. >> Um in
representing the uh the poorest district in America, one of the
smallest districts, too. Right. >> The most contiguous
and compact district. Yeah. >> and it was even more so
before >> And you have a third of your district lives under
the poverty line. Is that >> It's the lowest income district.
Uh about a third of the district uh is enrolled in SNAP. 70%
is enrolled in Medicaid. uh a third of them about a third are
born in other countries. Is that correct? >> A significant
immigrant population. >> Yeah. What does that what is the
mandate that you have in DC representing those >> Is to
make government work for the Bronx to protect critical programs
like Medicaid, SNAP, Medicaid or Social >> Is that what
you carry with you when you're in Congress? Do you is that what
you consider when you're like in a committee hearing? >> Yeah.
Well, I'm guessing you guys heard him talk about it. >> Yeah,
it's fine. >> Everything should be centered around the
Bronx first district. >> And for me, the Bronx is not only
where I live, it's who I am. Yeah. Um, >> I tell my constituents,
even when I leave the Bronx for Washington DC, the Bronx never
leaves me. The most important lesson my mother taught me is never
forget where you came from. And I'm from the Bronx, and I will
I lived in the Bronx my whole life, and I probably will die in
the Bronx, >> guys. Draft. >> I'm so sorry, Adam.
I'm so sorry. >> Back to this to the episode. >> I
just don't care about that. >> Something interesting that's
happened in the Bronx is in the last gen. >> That was all
that was all like political stuff. I knew that that was not going
to be quite as good, but I didn't know everything about Richie
Torres, so it's good to get a little background. >> Election,
from what I understand, there was the largest swing towards uh
the Republican party. >> One of the largest in 2012, >> Obama
won, Barack Obama won 96% of the >> in New York 15 in the
Bronx. >> Flash forward to the 2024 election, there's a
more than 22 point swing toward Donald Trump. >> Um why
is the Democratic Party losing the most vulnerable people in
America then? What do you attribute that? Well, the Democratic
Party is hemorrhaging support among working-class people of color
throughout the country. >> why is that? >> You know,
AAM razor holds the simplest explanation is almost always the
best. The simple explanation is inflation and >> we had
the highest inflation in more than four decades. So, if you're
paying double or triple the cost for groceries and gasoline,
>> you're going to lash out at those in power at the establishment.
>> You you say that the incumbency is just bound to lose
that election. Biden >> incumbency is perceived as failing.
Yes. >> Was there a way to win that election against Trump
>> if inflation is so bad? Is it
H that's tricky. All answers to that involve having a different
person as a candidate to start that that election, right? He
can't run a bunch of that election with Joe Biden as the candidate,
have him flame out and then switch >> impossible to win
that election. >> The odds were stacked against us because
inflation and the mismanagement of the migrant crisis. >> Uh
but
>> um you know, if we had the benefit of a full primary
process >> and if we had a stronger general election candidate,
>> maybe we could have won, but I don't know for sure.
But Donald Trump is a fatally flawed cate. So maybe we could
have won. >> You're you're a member of the >> That's
a That's a crazy That feels crazy to me that he just says it
like that just because Okay, for no other reason
I I don't know who this guy's allied to. Like is he just he's
just fine freelancing in the Democratic party? Like he's I guess
he just knows that Apex got him, right? He'd just be like, "Yeah,
they they [__] it up. Bad candidate.
Bad candidate." Okay. needed a better general election, a more
a more likable candidate for that. They [__] up.
That's I don't know if most them Dems say that. By the way, also,
I'll just say as an as a side thing. I suggested Gavin Newsome
purely on the fact that he was like an attractive white dude
and he would have won a whole bunch of votes that you wouldn't
have gotten otherwise. I maintain I think Gavin Newsome would
have won that election. I I know it's easy to say now, but I
think I think they should have got him Gavin Newsome. He was
like he was setting up for it and he didn't do it and he should
have he should have pulled the trigger. He should have gone for
the throat. I think they could have won with >> Least popular
Congress probably of our >> Uh I think we are we are more
we're less popular than colonoscopies. >> It sucks, dude.
>> Yeah. Does it suck? Does it suck to be the least? I
>> think there was polling that said we're more popular
than but we're less and more popularly more popular than Ebola.
>> You guys are losing for sure. >> Yeah. Well, >> you
guys are getting crushed by >> Hamas might be more popular
on college campuses than >> Oh, okay. Okay. But anyway,
but uh but I I looked at a Gallup poll the other day. Dude, this
is I I was actually started laughing. You just have to laugh
at this. You guys are 23 right now. That's pretty That's not
bad. >> Higher than I thought. >> That's high. >> You
Gavin wins on literally being an attractive white dude with great
hair. You don't understand how hard that carries the female vote.
I'm I'm just saying what we all know and you guys don't understand
it. You guys don't want to admit it, okay? That just that just
works. I live in a country where we lost where we had this guy
get elected. He was the most incompetent on planet Earth. Okay.
And he won like eight elections in a row just based on having
like a hairline is nuts. You guys, what is this? Oh my god. May
2024 13 >> means we have room for growth. >> 13.
That's you and the Republicans. 13. >> Yeah. Well, the
institution at large >> 13 is you poop your pants in front
of the whole school. Uh February 2024 12%. >> Yeah. So
it sounds like what was happen if Congress were not a if Congress
were a woman, you probably wouldn't go on a date with her. Is
that >> She's unpopular. I don't >> No. I What? She
could be like beautiful, you know? Like what do you mean? No,
you seem to hate Congress. So, >> I'm saying everyone does,
right? >> That's also >> 13% that approves or >> I
think that we have >> Captain Cappy Ban says cope. It carries
the mail vote, too. Just watch the fun clip. He's saying what
most men will be thinking. Yes. Yep. 100%. It doesn't suppress
the vote of all the all of like the ch
who would vote Democrat but are like, I'm I'm done with like
the
the DEI, right? It doesn't suppress that vote. It's actually
like a key thing. nobody cares about. >> Does it recognize
the runway a little bit and uh what got us here maybe, you >> Um
seeing the Marine Corps uh entering the second largest >> Romney
had better hair than Obama. Obama was like a an apparition that
will never appear again. Okay. Obama's like insanely charismatic.
Not an ugly guy, but insanely charismatic. You didn't have that
option. There wasn't an Obama. You didn't have the Obama card
to play. Okay. When you have the Obama card, you just win. You
just play the Obama card and you win automatically. All right.
But like, yeah, don't compare Romney to him. Romney was also
weird. Romney's got a bunch of weird with the whole being Mormon
thing. Mormons are weird. Okay. >> City in America. And
uh seeing the most vulnerable people in society just taken away
from their children and kidnapped and uh there are there are
there are facilities in our country right now surrounded by alligators.
There are facilities where there are cages with human beings
in them who have not been afforded any due process. And the sad
thing is is that you guys are um you're polling behind Donald
Trump right now. And uh >> that's not true. >> The
Democratic party has lower approval ratings than do than Donald
Trump. >> I think the story is more complicated >> What
is that? >> Yeah. So the latest polling from >> Oh,
wait. Is it not true or is it more complicated?
Which one is it? That's not true. Well, we could go look at the
math on that, but uh that is more complicated than that. You
don't have to say that second part if the first part is true.
>> CNN shows that the most important issue to Americans
is inflation, the cost of >> And on the most important
issue, Donald Trump is 25 points under war. >> And since
the November election, there's been a 34 point swing against
him. And that we as Democrats are more trusted on inflation than
he is. That's a huge >> Why are you guys like right now?
That is that is a cherry pick. Come on. >> You know, that's
a that's a >> inflation is the most inflation is the most
important issue. >> I want to talk to you guys about monarch
money. Um sometimes it's tough. No, Adam, stop shilling, bro.
>> You're in the House of Representatives and you have
to run every two years. >> Like, how long do you have to
wait till you just start running for the next one? After you
after you win an election, >> you you start immediately.
It's like you're in a >> constant state of campaigning.
>> Is uh campaigning and going to fundraiser, doing all
this stuff, is that a distraction from the work that you have
to do? >> It can, but but I feel like if you're effective
at governing, then it improves your your your ability to get
re-elected. So, if you're if you're a good congressman, >> Yeah.
You're going to be popular in your district and you're going
to be well positioned to be re-elected. >> Does it Does
it suck that you have >> We're getting into the good part
of the interview. Okay, that was all just pretext. All right,
that was all just prologue preview. Now we get to the good part.
I'm I'm locked in. Okay, so I've seen I've seen one or two clips.
This really kicks off. >> Sucks. Fundraising sucks. >> And
like uh because of Citizens United, >> it's nauseating
to ask people for money. >> Uh do you feel like it's eroded
people's like faith in the institution? Right. I feel like too
much money is too much time to spend on fundraising. Um, especially
if you're a frontline member >> who has a fiercely contested
general election every two years where tens of millions of dollars
are spent. >> You could be spending more than half your
time every week >> at a banquet. >> Uh, no. Or just
call time just dialing for dollars. >> You were criticized
I saw for Blackstone donation, right? And it's it's understood
that they are the architect. >> Wait, Blackstone of the
housing price is pretty much >> Yeah. I mean, >> do
you mean Black Rock? there. I mean, you receive contributions
from >> Blackstone's something else, right? No, there is
like an investment group called Blackstone that is like big,
but it's not Black Rockck big. >> Thousands of people.
>> Or employees from all over the place. >> You guys
send it back. Say off. >> Yeah. I'm not. >> So, they're
giving you a check. >> I I decide issues on the merits.
I don't know what others do, but I decide issues on the merits.
>> So, it's a just cuz check. >> Just cuz. >> They're
just giving you money just cuz they think you're dice. >> I'm
pretty sure that even there are lefty candidates who have gotten
money from people who are employed. Yeah, rank and file employee.
Sure. >> I figured like if you could maybe if you're like
this guy's >> you do know you know >> this guy's
making my constituents lives worse. You could you could be like
I don't want I I'm in a safe blue
>> People should judge me by my record. So by the
>> Oh, he is a politician after all. Seems kind of weird
to take a bunch of money from like u company that works against
your constituents, right? People should judge me by my record.
That's not a response. That's not a response to that question.
legislation I pass. >> I work seven days a week. >> I'm
visible in my district. I'm on the ground. I'm happy to. If you
ever want to take tours of my district, I'm happy to walk you
through my districts. >> Yeah. I'd like to I I mean, I've
been to the zoo in Yankee City. >> You going to walk me
through your district in a way that makes you um you walk me
through your district in a way that makes me not question your
ethics if you take money from people that work against the interests
of your constituents. Is that how it's going to work or >> Well,
not the actual projects, not the amenities, not the institutions.
>> Yeah. I can give you a sense of racially concentrated
poverty in a place like the >> So that's what my question
is is like >> where do you live? Which pro? >> I
live in Brooklyn. Yeah. And that's my >> Wait, wait, what?
That that wasn't the response. Wait, what? >> Yeah, I work
seven days a week. >> I'm visible in my district. I'm on
the ground. I'm happy to if you ever want to take tours of my
district. I'm happy to walk you through my districts. >> Yeah,
I like to I mean I've been to the zoo in Yankee City. >> Well,
not the actual >> I'm guessing those are part Yeah. parts
of his district that kind of hug slightly and aren't necessarily
massive parts of all right >> projects not the amenities
not the
>> I can give you a sense of racially concentrated poverty
in a place like the >> so that that's what my question
is is >> where do you live which borrow >> I live
in Brooklyn yeah and that's my question like >> so you
you might be divorced from the experience of racially concentrated
>> but what does that have to do with taking money from
blacks like I just feel like that's a deflection and I don't
want to I don't want to like an argument right now if you want
to argue Adam's an incredibly I think Adam puts a ton of work
into these interviews every single time, right? Cuz he knows
he knows the exact answers he's expecting and he knows what the
evasions are. I don't know if it's a I don't know how much I
want to differentiate between a deflection and evasion. It's
not that he's even like he's not even giving the appearance of
answering. He just changes the the subject. I feel like that's
an evasion. I don't you don't even want to touch it. Okay? You
don't even want to touch it. You just go to something else >> You
if you want to question my ability to represent my district,
I'm happy to show you what I do. >> I'm happy to bring
you to my district. What I'm calling introduce my >> What
I'm calling to question is the institution, right? I'm calling
it to question the system.
>> So like it appears you have this contract here that
prevents people from disclosing parts of their partnership with
Chorus.
Uh
look, these people all talked about being a Chorus partner in
like November before they signed that contract. Yeah. So you
see how that would be different than like when they signed that
contract and now monetarily tied to Chorus. No, they disclosed
it. But we want to talk about disclosing the financial relationship,
right? No, they said they were partnered with them months ago
before that existed. Yeah. Well, wait, isn't that confusing?
Like, I want to know, shouldn't you disclose that you're now
getting money? There's a financial relationship. There's a financial
tie. It's like the same. It feels the same. It's all the same.
It's like, dude, I'm I'm asking you a very clear question. Why
are you pretending you don't understand it? I >> mean,
you're functioning within a system, right? >> I've received
contributions from tens of thousands of people. I can't keep
track of every person. I'm not responsible >> for every
person. You forgot. >> I'm only responsible for what I
do. >> Okay. So, so you >> you can you can play the
gotcha game, but that's not >> I'm not trying to play the
game. I think you're used to like Anderson Cooper 360 and I'm
a guy. I'm from Cometown >> I'm not. I'm happy to answer
whatever question you >> Well, yeah, whatever. >> God,
that name hits a little bit harder when you're actually interviewing
Congress people.
I feel like you're used to people who are doing gotchas. I'm
from Cometown Podcast. Have you heard of Incel Sebastian?
My friend Nick does a fantastic Sebastian. Uh here's here's a
question for you. Um
I think like uh I think uh you've established yourself as the
fiercest uh champion of the state of Israel and Congress. >> I
I've never described myself in those terms. I >> I'm pro
Israel, but I those are terms. >> Well, I think maybe you've
been dubbed that. Okay. Listen, like I'm a person. Like I have
my own opinions on this. You have your own opinions. And this
is a really frustrating conversation to see people have on the
internet. I I don't get an opportunity to talk to to talk to
someone that's uh making decisions and supporting these things
that are a huge deal to people right now. Yeah. One thing that
I thought was interesting and I want to start with you is that
uh you described your first trip to Israel in 2015 as a life-changing
experience and I I just wanted just to follow the narrative of
like you growing up and and your struggles and then going into
the government like what what is what was that experience like
and what what bred that passion for Israel in you?
Uh, dude, you love Israel. You took a trip there. You love Israel.
What part of Israel did you really love? What What was the best
part? What really spiritually awakened you in Israel other than
the money? >> Well,
since I grew up poor my whole life, I never had an opportunity
to travel abroad. Yeah. >> For the first time ever, >> went
to a foreign country. >> It was actually >> Wait,
what? >> Cuz you went >> part of the reason went
abroad for the first time. >> What is What was that? >> What?
No, he did not. He did not just say that. That is not the answer.
That can't possibly be the >> passion for Israel in you.
>> Well, since I grew up poor my whole life, I never had
an opportunity to travel abroad. >> Yeah. The first time
I ever went to a foreign country. >> So, it was life changing
cuz you >> the first time I ever went to a foreign country,
they paid for my trip. I went to Israel.
Dude,
the reason I don't really care about those gazins getting, you
know, just air dropped every single day, not supplies, but bombs.
And the reason I don't give a is cuz uh Netanyahu flew me out.
Netanyahu flew me out once and it was a great time.
So what did you think when you went to like the West Bank or
Gaza, Richie? What did you think of the the suffering going there?
Did you go to Did you go to Hebron? Did you go to any of these
areas? Richie, where did you go in Israel? >> Part of the
reason went abroad for the first time. Life changing. But also,
you know, when you go to when you experience the complexity of
Israel, go to the old >> What did you see? Like what did
you witness like? >> Well, go to the old city. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I've been there. >> Yasham, which is the Holocaust
Museum. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Go to the Masada. You know,
Jews, escape >> I've hiked to Msada. >> The Gaza
Envelope. >> Went to Stro. Spoke to the local mayor who
said that >> you went to Gaza. >> I did not go. No.
>> What did you say? >> The Gaza envelope. He didn't
go to Gaza. He went to the Gaza Envelope and Strote. Strote,
I believe, being the closest city. The closest like, is it the
closest city or the closest um kibbutz to Gaza? Right. I think
Stro's famous for constantly having air raid sirens going off,
right? For constantly getting um rockets fired at it. >> Gaza
Envelope. >> No, Gaza Envelope, which is which is which
is right on the border with It's Israel, but it's right at the
border with Gaza. So, >> it's right next to the fence.
>> Yeah, it's in the proximity to >> What What's
it What's at the Gaza >> Like I've never heard that. State
Road. >> Stay wrote. Yeah. With the rockets. Go ahead.
Yeah. >> How far is Stay Road from Gaza? It's like a mile
or something. >> Yeah, within miles. >> Yeah. It's
right next to it. >> Yeah. Striking proximity to this small
place. The whole thing. Yeah. I mean, that's why was able to
so easily penetrate on October 7th >> the by getting over
the fence. >> Yeah. And it's so close. >> Yeah. No,
I mean I just want to know because it seems like it was powerful
and it seems like it's informed your record and I I that's what's
interesting to me. It's like your story and how you got here
and like I think it's narratively what what fascinates. >> Maybe
one day you'll give me >> the the best part is he he clearly
says he'd never been able to travel abroad implying Israel did
fly him there. He only went to like Israeli places. He basically
went on a propaganda tour and he bases all of his foreign policy
decisions about Israel on that propaganda tour. Didn't go see
the plight of any of the other people there. So he's just like,
"I love Israel cuz they flew me out once."
Like literally a what, a $2,000 trip and this guy's their strongest
defender. Come on, man. >> Tell it though. >> Why
are you annoyed by this question? >> I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
Uh, so I spoke to local mayor steroid
stero and >> steroid
steroid >> and he said to me that the majority of his children
struggle with post-traumatic stress >> because families
like his live under the >> Wow. And you felt a lot of empathy.
What if I told you that just one mile away, Richie, just one
mile away,
there were thousands of other children struggling with post-traumatic
stress? What if I told you that? Would would you feel a little
empathy then, Richie? Would you feel any empathy at all then
>> of relentless rocket fire? And I remember seeing these
bus stops doubling as bomb shelters. >> You know, I come
from the Bronx where people live in fear of bullets and guns,
but um you know, we in America do not worry about Canada and
Mexico firing rockets into American homes and >> You know,
we're a country of 330 million people. We're surrounded by >> oceans
and Israel is a tiny democracy the size of New Jersey >> that's
literally surrounded by both state and non-state actors that
are intent on wiping it off the map. Yeah. >> You know,
I left Israel with an empathy for the unique security situation
that Israel faces. >> Did you visit the ter occupied territories
while you >> I went into the not Gaza, but I went to the
Palestinian Ramal? Ramala. So, >> yeah. Ramala. >> Yeah.
And >> Oh, he went he went to Ramala. Okay, let's go Ramla.
>> What did you see when you were there? You know, we spoke
to Palestinians who obviously have a much more critical view
of of Israel and um >> and that didn't resonate as much
as like what what was your take away from hearing hearing the
mayor state his children have PTSD and then this guy's like uh
Israel's screwing with me. >> Well, look, I'm in favor
of a two-state
>> I feel like the just outcome lies not in the existence
of a state to the exclusion of a Palestinian state or the existence
of a Palestinian state to the exclusion of a state. It's the
coexistence of both. So I think >> I want to see the struggle
the both the Israeli and the Palestinian struggle for self-determination
to be reconciled in the form of a two-state solution. >> A
big topic nowadays is >> I don't think the Israelis are
struggling with self-determination. I think they solved that
problem in like 45 46 46 right and I don't think they've really
struggled with that since then. They've actually been self-determining
more since then. >> Campus anti-semitism you >> self-determining
a little more every >> working out against it. I just want
to know what you identify as the examples of this type of anti-semitism
in elite academic institutions. >> Yeah. So, there were
students at a cutuny hal. >> Where you had a violent what
I thought was an aggressive mob following them to a kosher restaurant
>> in the heart of New York City.
>> what were they doing? The mob. What was the mob doing?
>> Just following them and then barricaded
the restaurant and >> holding hurled insults at the patrons
and slamming the windows. You know, much of it is captured in
video footage. >> You know, harassing people simply for
>> Okay, hold on. Get me the video footage right now. Get
me the video footage. I want the video footage. Give me the most
traumatic video footage. Okay. I want Hold on. Let me Let me
go back >> to a kosher restaurant >> in the academic
institution. >> Yeah. So, there were students at a cutuny
hal. >> Where you had a violent rest of >> uh auti
What would this be? I don't know what this is. What does he say?
>> Following them to a kosher restaurant >> in the
heart of New York City. And they Oh, cu n y. I see a cutuny
student
protest follows people kosher restaurant. I'm just searching
stuff on the side. I want to see it. Videos. Uh,
can we find this
in protest kosher restaurant? Okay, I see some Instagram reels
of this. I think I got an restrictive video. Oh, it >> somebody
find me a better video. I'm looking, but I can't see it. >> And
then barricaded the restaurant and >> halding hurled insults
at the patrons
>> slamming the windows. you know, much of it is captured
in video footage and >> you know, harassing people simply
for
>> pro-Israel to me is wrong. >> Is there any other
examples like >> there's a restaurant? I mean, it's just
>> all we're hearing about is campus anti-semitism, radical
radical like is there a link between and the protests like has
is that established? >> There are students who have faced
harassment and intimidation because of their beliefs. There are
students who feel inhibited from expressing their or Zionist
identity because of the atmosphere of intimidation or harassment
on college campuses. You should speak to >> How have they
are you denying that there's any campus?
>> Protest outside of protest outside Mr. Broadway closer
dely
students died inside at a back to
>> If you're outnumbered significantly, I can see why that
would be concerning.
I I don't see any violence, but I can see why it'd be concerned
or >> I inhibited from expressing >> their Zionist
identity because of the atmosphere of intimidation or harassment
on college campuses. You should speak to this. How are you denying
that there's any campus anti-semitism or >> I well I'll
give you an example. Um I I know a younger person that is went
to UCLA and was attacked and is with a group of people on at
at the at a protest and they were attacked by the Proud Boys.
>> That's an empty case somebody considered. No, but the
Proud Boys were there for Israel and those are the guys that
did Charles Boys are there for >> Yeah, Proud Boys is like
white nationalists and white supremist. >> I'm telling
you right now, >> we're anti-Israel. Okay, >> listen.
I'm >> Why would the Proud Boys be anti-Israel? >> I'm
like a comedian, right? Like I hate when comedians, especially
on the internet, like speak with from a position of authority
with like about um crap that they don't know about. You know,
this is one topic >> I don't like. This is the one thing
Adam does that actually annoys me. He does like the He's trying
to be like John Stewart where John Stewart would do this thing
where he'd like kind of mog and then he'd be like, "I'm just
a comedian. I don't really know what I'm talking about." And
I don't really like it. If you actually put work into stuff,
you work hard to understand things. You shouldn't diminish that.
Even if it like if you think it's kind of like an attack on the
other person, right? I I don't like that. I don't know how to
explain it, right? That when you diminish yourself like that,
it just makes it feel weird to me that like
it doesn't make it better. I don't know how to explain it. topic
I feel like I can speak on and uh it >> on college campus
anti-semitism. >> No on uh on anti-semitism >> in
general because you haven't been in college how long two decades
right >> I'm telling you on my experience of anti-semitism
the last two years but uh the last two years have felt different
in America and um I don't know if you've been on Twitter recently
now a ton of people are questioning the validity of the Holocaust
having happened. Can you tell me with a straight face that that
that's those those are the 18-year-old kids at Colombia that
are doing that? >> The 18-year-old kids at Columbia. >> Are
they doing those posts about about the Holocaust never having
existed? You know who's doing it? >> No, we disagree here.
>> Wait, who is doing it? >> You think that it's
the >> So, I didn't put words in my mouth. >> It's
it's it's people on the right. Let me tell you, >> you're
suggesting that you're suggesting you're suggesting there's no
one on the far left that denies the Holocaust or downplays the
Holocaust. That's enough. >> What are you're doing moot
court right now? I'm telling you what it's like to be my experience
being >> Yeah, but there are others who are >> I'm
trying to see you're why why is one >> who's who's part
of the chosen people here, Mr. Torres. You or me. I'm trying
to tell you what my experience is as a member of the tribe. Please
don't deny my story and my lived experience. >> It's better
than the other. Why is one more important than the other? I'm
trying to share with you. You're in the government. I don't get
a chance to talk. Okay.
>> Um I think hatred of people has exploded in this country.
And I don't think it's I think it's because it's of our support
of what looks to be an absolute
And I think that >> you think that's a justification for
>> Here's the thing. >> You think Israeli government
policy is a justification for anti-semitism? My view is there's
no justification for anti. I think that >> there's zero
just >> uh there's a difference between justification and
explanation. If you want to solve a problem, you need to do analysis
and explain why that problem is happening. Justification says,
"No, no, no. I'm fine with the problem happening." Right? actually
that's you know that's actually preferable that that that thing
that's happening that's basically the solution to a different
problem right that's justifying you you can't solve a problem
without analyzing and understanding the causes right and saying
that saying hey I think this is because of it is caused by Israel
doing a atrocity that is not an excuse it is explaining why anti-semitism
is is exploding and obviously if that is the reason then cutting
down protests against that thing seem like not a solution to
anti-semitism They seem like they would not be a solution in
any way to anti-semitism. >> Justification for anti. >> Okay,
you're deflecting again. >> I'm not my position. >> What
does it look like to have a flag with a and I'm >> explaining?
Well, second says, well, explaining equals justifying in a lot
of people's minds. It's annoying on all levels. So, it can be
and I understand why justify why explaining feels like justifying
to people. I understand why it can feel that way, right? I'm
not doubting that it can feel that way for people, but usually
if you're explaining I feel like you're justifying it would be
like the explanation is followed by like no prescription at all.
If you just explain you don't want to say anything like when
I say no I feel like cracking down on you know protest against
the Israeli atrocity. I don't think that's a good solution. I
think that's we shouldn't do that. If I don't have any comment
and like hey we should you know do something to
inform people. I I don't know if I don't know what the answer
is in terms of like right-wing anti-semitism, like holocaust
denial, like true like, you know, global cabal anti-semitism.
I don't know what the solution is there necessarily, but I do
agree it's a problem, right? I just think the leftwing anti-semitism
that people go after it, it seems to me that it's from a totally
different place and conflating the two, it it actually with the
explanation in on both sides.
Yeah. >> For kids to be starving right now. And why is
my government I don't want to do this fight. Let's not do like
a yelling at each other thing. I really just for me it's for
me I had the the experience
>> it just sounds like you're justifying anti-semitism
which making me feel like >> are you >> uh so box
I think this is totally incorrect. Adam always does this. Adam
always does the character the bit for the first half and then
once he gets a feel for the person he like starts actually going
in and trying to pick apart cuz usually he's got a goal for having
the person there. Um I feel like it's it's only people he's like
friendly with that he keeps the character up the whole time and
he like p pokes the whole time. I think he did this with Jesse
Lee Peterson in some cases. I think he's done this quite a bit
where he like does actually say these things. This dude just
feel like he say he feels unsafe. >> I don't want to do
this fight. Let's not do like a yelling at each other thing.
I really just for me it's for me I had the the experience of
>> it just sounds like you're justifying anti-semitism
which making me feel like >> are you crazy right now? >> Why
would I making me feel >> It just sounds like you're justifying
anti-semitism which making me feel >> Are you crazy right
now?
>> I'm un maybe unsafe. I don't know what he says there.
It's just making me feel like uh it's making me feel You guys
think unsafe? I I thought uncomfortable was where he was going
and he just didn't finish it. >> Yeah, I was going to say
it makes me feel uncomfortable. >> Why would I do that?
You're telling you're doing the I'm thing. >> I'm not saying
you're wrong, but it's I'm not I think >> we'll do a different
We'll do a >> Israeli government policy should have no
bearing on >> if if you have disagreements with the Israeli
government, you should voice your criticism of the Israeli government
that there is no justification for intimidation or harassment
against Americans. I'm telling you as a right now that that we
are receiving a lot more hate because of >> like I would
say, how do I explain it? I don't think that a lot of those protests
are really going after people who are just on campus. I don't
think I've seen a lot of examples of that, although I've seen
some, right? I think it's usually when when people do get attacked
this protest, they're usually
right? Which it still doesn't justify them getting attacked,
but they're not being attacked because they're in that case.
they're usually being attacked because the protest is turning
violent in some way. From what I've seen, you know, four out
of five times
doesn't excuse the one out of five, okay? Doesn't excuse the
one out of five at all. But from what I've seen, it seems to
be the case that in most of these cases,
it is counterprotesters who who end up getting right now that
that we are receiving a lot more hate because of what the people
with a flag that as a Jews are on are doing to other people right
now. And I'm telling you as a person what how painful it is for
us to say and it hurts my stomach to say this and you're going
to say I disreg
this is a genocide
and that hurts to say that you could do that. It hurts because
we grew up with it with learning about what hatred is. We we
grew up learning about this and the same year the state of Israel
was established in 1948 the the the world saw the Holocaust and
they established standards for what a genocide is. it was the
savior
and the world said that this shouldn't be a thing that happens,
you know, and and and I just wonder like like it doesn't make
sense to me like like what like I don't know it it doesn't track
to me why there's this fixation with kids at a school that and
two examples of people at a restaurant that that there was banging
>> two examples. I mean there there are surveys on it.
>> Give me read the ADL surveys on it. >> It's hard
it's hard for me to talk about this in public.
It's you're being >> read the ADL surveys. Okay. Read the
ADL
>> That's mean. >> They they wouldn't have any bias.
They wouldn't have there wouldn't be any >> It's hard It's
hard for me to talk about this in public. >> I mean, you're
It's >> You're being That's mean. >> No, no, I'm
not being clear. It's an emotional topic. >> All right.
I'll share with you what >> I'm not >> I lived there
to be mean. Sir, I I lived there when I was 18. And I grew up
a >> And we were told and our whole community in this country
is told that we have to defend Israel and love Israel because
it will stop at the Holocaust. It will stop another Holocaust
from happening. And I my parents, my dad was born in 1951.
That was 6 years after the these atrocities. His friend's parents,
he knew these people that had been >> they banned a player
from events because they were Zionist. Are you talking about
Zionism is not that? That's not anti-semitism. You could say
it's like uh discrimination against, you know, a political position
or something, but it's not anti-semitism, anti-in hell, these
skeletons
and and it terrified us and and the understanding in our community
is that we have to defend Israel,
but it's I live there. >> Talk about the smash goofy settlement.
>> I could the smash community work on banning before they
ban
or they suggesting that there might be an overlap. I'm not sure
which. and Israel,
but it's I lived there and I went to a a settlement at the end
of my year there and I looked down the hill at a Palestinian
village and I saw how they lived and I turned back and I looked
at the settlement and saw how they lived and people live in a
in a world where they're demeaned and dehumanized and surveiled
constantly by people in and this isn't in Gaza by people in SWAT
team outfits with with semi-automatic weapons. And that's what
the world is seeing. And you keep telling me that the problem
is someone's getting yelled at at a restaurant. I'm sorry. >> You're
complaining two different issues. I don't know. >> Please,
just please. Me saying this to you right now will hurt people.
>> I I'll be honest. I'm just very disappointed that Adam
didn't break out his fetching voice a single time that I've heard
in this entire interview. Like it it was literally he can do
the impression. It's literally built for this interview and he
hasn't done it a single time. It's [__] up. >> Please
just please me saying this to you right now will hurt people
in my own family. Okay? Because because this is a very important
thing to us and the fact that I still care about being is embarrassing.
I should just be a guy. But but it but this is feels like a stain
on our history and it feels like it's changed what being is because
what being is isn't Israel. Judaism has existed for 4,000 years.
This is a country for 75 years. You know, like it it is the oldest
one of the oldest monotheistic religions. It's it is anti-semitism
is one of the oldest forms of hatred.
People in my life are going to be mad at me about this, but but
I'm saying this because I am, you know, and and and I don't understand
why you would >> how you
I I want >> I feel like I'm here to be lectured. Not >> shut
up. That's not nice. You can't talk that way, >> dude.
Ah, >> why are you But more important than than >> no one's
saying no one's saying any
>> What happened? You had you went to the beach at in Israel.
What? You went to a restaurant or something?
>> A nice restaurant. Like listen, >> never been
never never even been to the televade. So >> this is the
year 2020.
How? How is this guy so bad at answering questions? What the
Have you Did you go to a nice restaurant in Israel? I've never
even been to the Tel Aviv Pride Parade. The in Israel. What?
You went to a restaurant or something?
>> A nice restaurant? Like listen? >> Never been
Never even been to the telev pride parade. So >> this is
the year 2025. The world is seeing something that looks terrible
and it's being done in my name and I don't know what to do. >> But
the war began on October 7th. >> No, it didn't. Yes, it
did. >> You're those those crazy bloodthirsty Palestinians.
The Israelis were just sitting there doing nothing. Nothing had
happened in the past, you know, 60 70 years. All right. And these
people just broke out of somehow they were fenced in. I don't
know how that happened. Okay. Somehow they were fenced in and
they broke out and they killed a bunch of for no reason.
That's insane.
How did How did they allow this to
>> Systematically murdered and made you can you know you
want you want down a rabbit hole. We >> By the way, that's
not to say that Israel that those Israeli civilians deserve that
in any way. They obviously did not every single civilian killed
on October 7th is a tragedy in and of itself. Okay, they they're
killing a terrorist attack. It's incredibly right. But obviously
obviously there are there are there are things that happened
before that that led us to expect something like that could happen
one day. Right. >> No no I need I need to pull it back
a little bit here. >> And I don't know what to do. >> But
the war began on October 7th. >> No it didn't. >> Yes
it did. >> You're systematically murdered and made and
you can you know you want down a rabbit hole. We fundamentally
disagree
murdered and maimed and mutilated and abducted and tortured thousands
of people. That's not television. That's a fact. That's reality.
You can deny it. You can downplay it. >> You're dying October
7th. >> Well, you seem to be pro October 7th. You're doing
I'm pro. >> I never said you were pro. You're putting words
in my mouth. >> It is. >> But you seem to be downplaying
it. >> There. For the last 17 years, people have been under
a blockade where they cannot leave.
If you were born in a place and there's a fence there and there's
a guy with a gun on the other side and he says you can't go anywhere,
would you like that guy? >> You're born in a pretty situation
there, Richie. Imagine if somebody had a gun to your head saying
you can't leave that situation. you were stuck in the [__]
projects in the Bronx for the rest of your life. Would you be
super happy, Richie? Seems like your ability to leave and make
something of yourself has helped you. You've changed your life
situation. Those people don't get that >> If you deem if
you treat people like animals, sometimes they're going to lash
out. Look, >> I sincerely believe, maybe I'm wrong, that
if if if Palestinians were governed not by a terrorist organization
like Gaza, but by a regime that was able and willing to make
peace with Israel, the situation would be fundamentally different.
The preconditions for this happening are undeniably
something that the Israeli government was fully aware of.
Why would BB Okay. >> You think October 7th was justified?
>> Okay, I'm happy you said that. >> Are you listening
to what I'm saying right now? >> I'm listening to what
you're saying. >> Why would the Israeli government
What's >> Dude, he's just like such a transparent.
It's like Dude, this is a guy I can tell that he didn't do well
in college. which I can tell that he wouldn't have really made
something of himself outside of Congress cuz you can tell that
this guy just sort of gets handed his talking points by Apac.
And those are his talking points. He doesn't look into this.
Bro, I'm starting to doubt he even went on this trip to Israel.
He just takes the money. He just takes the money. He takes talking
points. There's no belief here. There's no connection to like
some synthesis in his brain. It's just he just spews the talking
points
God, I was so annoyed when this guy picked up on the Twitch anti-semitism
thing and he picked the worst clip. The only clip of Assan that
you like can't justify at all in reality. Like being upset with
him about the only one where he's talking about how like, yeah,
even if there were rap on October 7th, that doesn't change my
calculus about the genocide one iota. That's like a totally defensible
position. And Richie Torres tweets it cuz he's a [__]
brain dead Zogbot. Okay. and that's the one they pick up that
I was I was still on the uh you know focus on campaign
and I was just like oh that's that's I can't defend that that's
that's a horrible clip and but he sees it and he's like oh this
guy thinks uh this guy thinks that like just that that the rap
don't change anything about this well you know what [__]
this guy
so stupid god I hate >> eradicate the Jew people and the
Jew is that right that's what I'm asking >> Zogbot huh
yes Zogbot But yes, Richie Torres is a soulless Zogbot. That's
what Richie Torres is. Yes, he he has himself he has his ass
for sale and he takes his Apac money and he keeps getting run
in Congress and he's got a whole sweet system set up.
Okay. All right. >> Okay. Then why would they? >> By
the way, I don't even know other than Torres, I don't know if
I'd say that about some other people in Congress, right? In the
same way. Torres is like easily the worst one. Easily the worst
one directly give money literally bags >> Isn't Zog anti-semitic?
Yeah, Zog is definitely anti-semitic. This slime guy says no,
but I I think I think Zagbot is uh I am doing a little anti-semitism
there. Okay, but it's uh it's prophylactic anti-semitism. It's
required anti-semitism to make sure people understand the stakes
here. Okay. There's some little some little microaggressions
we do to like make sure people understand that, hey, it's not
all Yeah, it's kind of anti-semitism, but it's a funny word.
It is a funny word. Can you explain the slur, please? ZOG means
Zionist occupied government. It's a it's a long been a white
supremacist like trope talking about how run America, run the
world. Okay, Zionist occupied government. Zionists people run
the American government. Right. Since the popularity of the war
in Gaza has cratered in America and politicians have failed to
change their rhetoric, people start to say, right, people start
to say zog unironically because they don't understand why when
there's very little public support for this war, very little
public support for Israel's actions that their government officials
still seem to be locked step in supporting it. Right? That's
confusing to people. Hey, we the American people don't really
like this stuff. Why are our government officials totally on
board with it? Then they find out that there's this term that
a bunch of funny people online use called Zog that talks about
how people have like some control over the government through
money through Apac all these things, right? Yeah. I can explain
exactly where Zog's from, but unfortunately you have to confront
the reality that once people see, you know, politicians can't
this is the first time ever that politicians can't see popularity
for an issue dropping and they don't flip-flop immediately, right?
I think that starts to stick in people's head a little bit. I
think I think Oh, why did I Why did I get mentioned by Destiny
here? Oh, he's he's justifying doxing Doobie because Doobie talks
some [__] Cool. He's going to stand on business here,
I guess. Listen, guys. I should be able to dox Doobie cuz Doobie
talks about me. Let's go. Let's check it out. He posts this image
right here. He says, "This is just one day in Pisco server."
This is just one day on the 20th of August. The height of this.
Okay. This is one day in Pisco server. Seems like it might have
been him and Dan doxing Jtock in Pisco and Kiwi Farms. Uh
so he's trying to talk about um I'm just hardcore doxing anyone
he can find information on now. So he's talking about how this
guy is doxing people. So he adds stand to this. That was the
only thing I'd say maybe is not necessarily maybe not necessarily
true. Yo, it's one of the thing one thing to share explicit videos
is another to tacitly entertain contact with some of you when
you're nervous. Some of your nervous is underage. account that
posted JSTO. Uh, don't talk about that. I'm like, don't associate
with Destiny. Yeah, I'm not interested in supporting anything
he's involved with. Dan Sman literally has subpoenas sent just
to abuse them and get people's personal info so he can public
dox them. That happened. Pixie is not the one preventing Destiny
from going after the solo guy. True. True.
Uh, wait. Is this really Pisco server?
I don't think this is Pisco server. Is this CPCA and Pisco's
server? Oh, it's not also it's also not just one day. How does
what? So, hold on. Let me Let me go back to the tweet. The tweet
is right here. So, the tweet is right here. This is just one
day in Pisco server. He's So, this is not It's two days already.
By like the second part, we can already see that this is a different
day. And I'm not sure that this is Pisco server, right? I don't
even think they have white names in Pisco server, right? 99%.
So, it's literally just It's just so lazy. It's so insanely lazy.
Like, he's he's so lazy. It's It's just insane to me. Yes, they
apparently sent Dan Cam when they were trying to find out find
Rose. So, it might be over that. So, he's talking about this
in I I don't think uh I don't think we have proof Dan was in
that. Honestly, I feel like Dan was pretty out on this. Um yeah,
talking doesn't work in a docks. Also, he's just talking about
Sorry, he's toxing. He's just talking about Destiny's done, right?
Seems like excuse, but might be true. It came out recently that
Dan organized a Discord group to try to find and smear Hassan's
family. Uh it was a Discord group arranged for a different purpose
but adjacent purpose. It was the Twitch anti-semitism stuff and
they were trying to do this. That's surprising. This is a third
day now. They had a relationship with Dan as a proxy. Dan has
been sponsoring the show with his redact.dev thing. This is about
Ethan. This is obviously true. This is a fourth day in a different
server where he's talking about how Dan has been the head of
harassment campaign publicly doxing people for over a year now.
I'm sure he and his family have been getting plenty of heat for
a long time. Uh, this is actually true that Dan has been at the
head of a public campaign this or a campaign that has been publicly
doxing people, right? One day, it's not one day, it's multiple
days. He's so He's just so lazy. Anyway, it's already disproven.
Let's finish the interview. I'm going to pull it back. We're
going to start this section over again a little bit cuz I'm I
got taken out of it. I got a notification on my phone that this
was in my replies saying,
it's whatever. We'll uh we'll continue because because this is
a very important thing to us." And the fact that I still [__]
care about being Jew is embarrassing. I should just be a guy.
But but it but this is feels like a stain on our history and
it feels like it's changed what being is because what being is
isn't Israel. Judaism has existed for 4,000 years. This is a
country for 75 years. You know, like it is the oldest one of
the oldest monotheistic religions. It's it is anti-semitism is
one of the oldest forms of hatred. People in my life are going
to be mad at me about this, but but
I'm saying this because I am, you know, and and and I don't understand
why you would be Richie Torres. His programming is locking up.
Okay, we keep his his programming is locking up. He's like, "Wait,
this guy's and I'm trying to defend Israel. I don't know. What
do What do I say? I I've never even been to the Tel Aviv Pride
Parade, guys. What do I say?" Whoops. I paused again. Look how
how you >> I I want >> I feel like I'm here to be
lectured. Not >> shut up. That's not nice. You can't talk
that way. Why are one said but more important than than others?
>> No one saying no one's saying any
>> what happened. You had you went to the beach at in Israel.
What? You went to a restaurant or something? >> Here it
comes. >> A nice restaurant. Like this is >> I haven't
even been to the television. >> This is the year 2025.
Yeah. >> The world is seeing something that looks terrible
and it's being done in my name and I don't know what to do. >> But
the war began on October 7th. >> No, it didn't. Yes, it
did. >> You're a Hamas systematically murdered and maimed.
You can you know you want you want We're going down a rabbit
hole. We fundamentally disagree. Weas murdered and maimed and
mutilated and abducted and tortured thousands of people. That's
not television. That's a fact. That's reality. You can deny it.
You can denying October 7th. >> Well, you seem to be October
7th. You're >> I never said you were pro. You're putting
words in my mouth. >> It is. >> But you seem to be
downplaying it. >> Are you justifying October 7th? Are
you saying October 7th was justified? No. Why would you say that?
That's be saying you're supporting if you said October >> For
the last 17 years, people have been under a blockade where they
cannot leave.
If you were born in a place and there's a fence there and there's
a guy with a gun on the other side and he says you can't go anywhere,
would you like that guy? If you deem if you treat people like
animals, sometimes they're going to lash out. Look, I sincerely
believe, maybe I'm wrong, that if if if Palestinians were governed
not by a terrorist organization like Gaza, but by a regime that
was able and willing to make peace with Israel, the situation
would be fundamentally different. >> The preconditions
for this happening are
something that the Israeli government was fully aware of.
Why would BB then Okay, here. >> You think October 7th
was justified?
>> Okay, I'm happy you said that. Are you listening to
what I'm saying right now? >> I'm listening to what you're
saying. >> Why would the Israeli government
what's to eradicate the people in the state? Is that right? >> That's
what I'm Yeah. >> Okay. Then why would they directly give
money literally bags of cash? >> Oh no. Adam, please. Adam,
please.
>> Not this one. This is No, this is not a good argument.
This is actually a bad argument. in suitcases through the Qataris.
Billion nearly I think over a billion dollars in cash during
>> Why is this a bad point? Because this is money that
they laundered through the Qataris back into Gaza because uh
Abbas was was keeping funding from I believe the Qataris as well.
He was not allowing that money to go to Gaza because Abbas wanted
a wanted like literally like riots in Gaza from none of their
services working. This is money meant to like keep the lights
on in Gaza, like meant to pay for to keep like stuff maintenance
to pay government workers, right? And and yes, Netanyahu basically
decided that like well boss is holding this back so they can't
get it. We might as well let it through and let us go and give
it to them cuz then we have some hope of tracking it. Like we
can actually like, you know, attach something to it, have some
intel on it, and know where it's going. government workers. It
turns out that when it comes down to brass tax and preventing
all out like preventing Gaza from turning to GTA 5, they suddenly
realize, oh, that is a government. That is somebody we're going
to work with. We do actually want them to have money. We don't
want that place to be a disaster zone 24/7 because then we get
blamed for it.
Yes. Like it turns out that the know that too. Okay. BB Netanyahu
knows that. He knows it. He he's very happy to like make sure
that runs properly and talk to officials
>> this last 17 years. >> That's a fair point. It's
a great >> If if one of those kids at Columbia wrote a
$5 check to you'd say send them to Gitmo for being a terrorist.
>> It's a fair point. >> Does that make Benjamin
Netanyahu a
>> He's supporting terror. >> The United States,
it seems to me the United States and Israel could have shut off
the spigot and did not do so. I don't know why, but but that
was a failure. There's no question. I uh I I >> How could
they shut off that spigot? That spigot's from the Qataris.
>> I think that what what I see is the reason why our government
provides $25 billion
to something that looks this horrific to people. I think it's
the same reason. I think it makes it look like there's the control
of the government, but really what it is is the more boring answer.
It's the reason why the government and you guys don't get done.
It's the reason why Sandy Hook can happen. You guys can't do
gun reform. It's because >> why why can't we do gun reform?
>> Because because special interest groups can buy influence
in our government. >> Which political part is against gun
>> The NRA has a power. >> It's the Republican party.
>> We allow government our government to >> I thought
Netanyahu gave money to so they didn't rely on the PA on the
PA. Yes. Yeah. Like he let the money go through. I thought it
was I'm pretty sure if you look at that article Matt NLT
it is it is because Abbas is not allowing payments to flow through
the PA to in the Gaza Strip and that that Netanyahu speculated
that yes Abbas is the head of the PA was the head of the PA.
Uh BB speculated that this this was because Abbas was calculating
that if there were riots in Gaza that the Israelis would have
to come in and quell those riots and then eventually that would
lead to a bunch of getting killed and then the PA could move
back into Gaza and maintain and regain control of both Gaza and
the West Bank. That was what BB thought. So he was like, I'll
just let the money flow through us because that we're not going
to go and put people like boots on the ground in Gaza.
That's that's what he thought back then. I've I've read that
article. I'm pretty confident it's the same article we're all
referring to. >> To be flooded with cash and money. >> It
was also to keep these these people Yes.
But it wasn't to keep them separate by by weakening one of the
two. It was to uh it was that if the PA control both, they don't
want a united government controlling both. Yes. So, it is to
keep things split. Absolutely. But it is a little bit different
than where where people or how people perceive it. If I remember
correctly, I'm pretty sure I do because I've read that article
at least twice. >> And it's what's scary to me is that
it looks that people are starting to question the Holocaust ever
happening. How could maybe they invented the >> You're
blaming
You're blaming Israel for Holocaust denial. >> I'm blaming
our I'm blaming our government for supporting a genocide, >> but
it is unfathomable in my heart and it breaks my heart that we
could be capable of it. >> I think we should move on. >> Why
is that? >> Just one minute.
>> Just doesn't engage. Okay. He just like kind of soullessly
lets the attacks flow off of him and then I just think we should
move on. We just don't we just don't agree, man. We just don't
agree. We just don't agree, man. >> I don't think that
>> Adam sounds like Adam might be at the point of crying
on this. Archangel. So Archangel says Adam sounds like he's always
at the point of crying. He might be at the point of crying here.
This is something he feels like extremely passionate about. Unironically,
he feels very passionate about this,
right? Like he's he he very obviously cares. He runs like a political
show. Is he sick though? No. I think he I think he's absolutely
like bordering on tears right now.
He feels like he bought he bought, you know, he was lost in the
sauce. He believed everything people told him about Israel. I
have to defend that with with all of my being. And now he he's
been to the West Bank. He's been he's been able to see how, you
know, Palestinians live. And he feels like he was propagandized
and he's allowed something in his name that he feels is reprehensible
and he feels emotional about it. Right? It's pretty easy to understand.
If you thought you'd been, you know, softly supporting other
people being tormented for their entire lives, that might with
you, right? >> I think I'm talking to you like a about
where I come from and and that it feels different. And maybe
I have a different >> You have a different perspective.
>> But um >> I know people have a a perspective that's
different from yours and >> with a much smaller platform
than you. >> I'm I'm not I hate this conversation. You
know, I have it with my family. You >> it's it's not something
and I love my family. If it were up to me, we would not be having
this cuz we're speaking a foreign language. >> My family
uh grew up in South Africa, >> The foreign language. Human
emotion. I I'd rather not have this conversation. You're speaking
a foreign language. You have like these emotions. I don't know
what's happening right now. I'm actually Can I get some money?
Is somebody going to pay me for being here? >> We were
like Eastern Europe that literally we thought we were going to
Ellis Island. >> My grandma all the granny's stayed and
my my parents whole generation of South African Jews left. people
and
>> yo Max, thank you for the five gifted.
Let's go.
>> Message received, Max. Message received. I don't know
what the message is yet, but message received. Okay, understood.
Understood. Can we uh guys, we are six subs away. I'm not chilled
yet. Six hour six subs away from another two hours on the stream.
Let's get those six subs in right now. I'm not going to spend
a lot of time chilling tonight. It's a chill stream. We're just
doing chill [__] Okay. And uh when I was a kid like
growing up I used to write all my uh like uh who's my hero essays
on Nelson Mandela and uh he was like a hero of mine right and
uh he was also you know in prison and you know for terrorism
too. I don't want to get it. You're going to go I don't I'm not
debating how good he was called that and and he went to my synagogue.
>> The message is Aryan Brotherhood target destiny when
phase 4 commences. Okay. You know what not message received Max
but thank you for the money. I appreciate that. Okay. Disavow.
Disavow. Disavow.
And And also in a non-joking sense, also disavow. Do not want.
We do not advocate violence. Okay. I got to bring it down. I
was just laughing along with the show. Okay. With the interview
here. Richie Torres being totally soulless. All right. >> You
know, for terrorism. >> Oh, I'm not smiling. I'm not smiling.
I'm not I'm not smiling. Okay. >> I don't want to get it.
You're going to go I don't I'm not debating how good. He was
called that and and he went to my synagogue after he got out
of prison. Mediva and and he uh and he spoke to like all the
grandmas who like we're still there and they didn't have to move
cuz black people could vote and he said tell your kids to come
back cuz we need them to build our country. I don't know. I I
think that I I don't see what's wrong with people being afforded
the right to vote. >> Do you think that's what means when
it says free Palestine from the same? To me, it seems like maybe
if there's a recognition that people were cleared off their land
in 1948, >> but there are those >> there are those
who only want a state and there are those who only want a Palestinian
state >> that they can off >> and we should be advocating
for the coexistence
in a Palestinian state. I continue to believe I continue to believe
that two-state solution ultimately is the inevitable path forward.
That is >> it's stupid. You know, there were there were
a thousand Jews who were murdered before the establishment of
Israel. Like half a century before the establishment of Israel.
>> Half a thousand. Yeah. There were each other and Palestinians.
Yeah. >> It was a war. What? Yeah. There was a civil war
in the British mandate of Palestine. Yes, that happened. >> One
massacre. >> I It doesn't make sense to me this uh in in
2025. >> The only point was was there was >> Sir,
was there only a massacre in is it Habbron? Is that the one where
uh the got taken out? All right. I feel like there was also Oh,
why do I always lose it? Uh what's the one where they use the
the loudspeakers to clear them out? Or is that getting closer
to 4748? That might not be during the civil war. Yeah, I'm more
thinking of uh like the preludes to plan and maybe plan. I'm
not thinking of the actual civil war >> against before.
>> I need to if I want to talk about this topic, I have
to go back and do so much history. God >> thousand. Yeah,
there were each other and Palestinians. Yeah. The bra massacre.
I it doesn't make sense to me this uh in in 2025. >> The
only point was was there was violence against you before the
establishment of the state of Israel. >> There was violence
against Palestinians and there was an ethnic cleansing in >> The
Habbran massacre. >> What are you talking about right now?
You're the government.
>> I didn't see his delivery.
Yes, there was a war. There was the Habbran massacre.
Yeah, there was there was a there was violence against Palestinians,
too. The Habbran massacre.
The Habbran Massacre. The Habbran ma the
He's like shorting out. >> Listen, I just I'm sorry. You're
not familiar with the Habbran Massac in >> He just keeps
saying it. >> Well, you're saying that that >> Darius
was the entire ethnic cleansing in 1948. >> Israel was
>> Well, this is such a This isn't even a good argument.
>> Hold up. Israel, >> what are you talking? >> I
don't I didn't realize we were >> I don't want to do it,
but you're saying the Jewish state was established by international
law, right? The UN passed a resolution. It's that recognized
the establishment of a Jewish and there were a number of Arab
countries including Egypt that declared war in Israel. The war
of independence and Israel won the >> The Palestinians
didn't declare war on them. There were just people that were
living there and they were kicked off >> way. There were
300,000 Jews that were ethnically cleansed. >> You you
just have to give this up. I don't know why like I'm kind of
I was Zionist leaning. I don't know where I am anymore honestly
with all the [__] Israel's done. I've not really
taken a lot of time to reanalyze like how how much I kind of
believe Israel has a right to exist. Like I think there should
be a state. I don't know that that is where a purely like ethnostate
should exist. Okay. I don't know how much I believe in that anymore.
I haven't really reanalyed it. So I'll say I'll go back to like
um I'll go back to what my position was before. I was a Zionist.
But it was with the understanding that like the Palestinians
had a totally legitimate and obvious
real grievance for how they were treated, how a lot of the civilians
were treated leading up to the the war in 48, right? That's absolutely
true. If you don't understand that they had a real grievance
for how they were treated, that there were really bad things
that happened to them and that those things probably should be
accounted for for any like joint state to exist. If you don't
understand that, then like I don't know. I don't I didn't even
know how you could like you just haven't read the history
there were Jew you don't you know how many Jews there are >> not
by the Palestinians not talking about the talking about the broader
Arab >> so why do the Palestinians have to bear the responsibility
of the >> yeah yeah sorry Kringle kesh I'm just saying
that like I used to feel like they had a right to be there and
they they like establish themselves now practically you can't
really kick them out so like probably it needs to be a solution
that works with Israel not against it but I'm just saying that
like I don't know that I feel like they have the right to exist
there or something like they've got some ordained right to exist
there. I just don't feel that way anymore. I used to feel like
they won the war, they they persevered and they've earned the
right to exist there like as that state and I don't think that
should ever be taken away. And now I'm like, you know, I don't
it's like a principal position that I just don't necessarily
feel quite the same. And I thought they'd earned the right to
exist there as basically like an ethnostate. Like basically they've
earned the right to stay there as a state that is majority. And
I don't believe that that's probably the place where it changes
where like I don't think majority is something you've like earned
anymore. It seems like that has been abused to continue to oppress
a people and I don't know that I feel like I'm comfortable with
that in the same way anymore.
I don't know. I don't know what the solution is. So like I said,
I haven't thought about it. I haven't thought about like all
the downstream effects of how I feel about this.
>> The frog just tipped $15.
>> Israel is committing a genocide. Palestine is committing
terrorism. But who the worst of all is JSTLK permitting me to
sleep with more IP content?
>> Too bad, Kermit. Today's a comfy day. So, you're here.
You're strapped in. I will continue to commit genocide on your
on your awakenness, I guess. I don't even know how to All right.
Thank you for the 15, though. That puts us what? Two subs away,
I think. I think that's two subs
from another two hours on the stream, guys. Two subs. Let's go.
The Algerians kicking the can. >> Why do Why do the Palestinians
bear the responsibility of Egypt invading? Israel has been a
state for 77 years.
>> You're proposing You're proposing to undo an established
state. >> No, I know people that live there. I have family
that live there. I don't think What are you proposing? >> I'm
proposing a democracy.
>> I'm proposing
an extensive demographic study of what was taken and what was
lost. Extensive reparations for what that was taken. And a truth
and reconciliation process where where we can end this. What
we're seeing right now is that members of the Israeli government
are talking about clearing that and Trump, our president, is
talking about putting a jet ski museum
>> And you're that's the reality right now. >> The
far right. Yes, >> the Sorry, I'm saying this. I'm basically
red 473 asks why. So red 473 said, "So should the Kurds have
a state?" I think yeah, I believe in a Kurdish state that like
I I believe they've kind of earned the right to to have that
given that they've like been historically oppressed in every
state they've been a minority in. um in in a very similar way
to Jewish people, right? It sort of went along with my Zionist
belief in a lot of ways. And maybe I'm starting to reconsider
that a little bit. You ask why. Uh Red goes on to ask why that's
going to be a can of worms, too. I understand it's a can of worms.
I'm saying that like I do think that there is something for when
you're a small diaspora in multiple different states. You just
tend to get like the raw end of any deal. And I don't know, it
it feels like
it feels like it starts with having somewhere where your people
can exist without being, you know, predated on and then you build
out from there. Seems that way. Just seems that >> Reject.
So >> what the far right? I'm talking about the government
and the generals that are that are >> uh I'm talking about
what people deserve. I don't think guys everyone's like, "Wait,
do you want to do you want to make this happen?" No, I'm saying
they deserve it. I'm not saying they get it. Listen, there's
a reason there's only one Israel. Okay, that's nuts. They had
to they they had to pull some crazy [__] to make
that happen. Could you give the Kurds land without displacing
anyone and avoid I mean
possibly but it would involve moving people around and we generally
don't move populations like that around >> museum there.
>> I just read another question but could you give the
Kurds Kringle Kesh says but could you give the Kurds uh land
without displacing anyone and avoid it just ending up in the
same situation? I think so. But it would involve moving populations
like in a pretty massive basis. I'm not sure that that really
>> Anyway, I'm going to continue. I'm not going to continue.
That's the reality. The far right. Yes. >> I reject. So
>> what the far right? I'm talking about the government
and the generals that are that are in charge of Israel. >> The
Bengavir, the smallers of the world. That's a view cabinet. >> Yes.
And I reject them. >> That's what is saying they want to
do to >> I'm sorry. >> I mean
I mean Hamas murdered thousands of people. So there's no >> Smoltridge
has the guy from the cave of the patriarchs hanging up in his
office, doesn't he? Or is that Bengavir? I think Bengavir or
Smoltric. One of them has the the assassin from the cave of the
patriarchs who shot all his families. Bengavir. Okay, Benavir
has it like no that guy's that guy's idol is a >> So what?
Yeah. Yeah. How far is so why do the Palestinians have to Jewish
state was established by international law? What was taken and
what was
>> remembering to read the question before answering it
would make you 20% cooler. >> I am doing that. I literally
have gone back every time and made sure I did that. Shut up,
Rainbow Dash. But also, two subs, guys. Two subs. >> Extensive
reparations for what that was taken and a truth and reconciliation
and you're that's the reality right now. >> The far right.
Yes, >> it's the far right. I >> reject. So, >> what
the far right? I'm talking about the government and the generals
that are that are in charge of Israel. the Bengavir, the smolders
of the world. That's a view. >> They're the cabinet. >> Yes.
And I reject them. >> That's what saying they want to do
to >> I'm sorry. >> I mean,
I mean murdered thousands of people. So there's no >> So
what does that mean? >> The is a terrorist organization
for murdering innocent children and
>> How how many civilians have been in this >> The
war is a tragedy. But >> is short circuiting? Wait,
civilians is what makes you the worst? Oh, I've got some numbers
for you, my friend. I've got some numbers I I need you to take
a look at real quick. 90% of them have been but the >> 90%
of them have been
>> people people have been killed war it's been a tragedy
>> they killed people way >> okay so yeah uh see
I don't want to now I have to be I'd have to be equally soulless
to him to continue this to argue this but like from from his
frame you would just argue well the war started when they imprisoned
all these people in Gaza when they when they fenced it up and
kept them blockaded Let's call let's say the war started there.
You can keep going backwards to try to reassign blame, but then
it's all going to go, well, this has all been a war the whole
time and everything's justified. That's useless. You're just
going to say people die in war. You're not going to take any
accounting of like how many civilians are dying and and what
the what what this is all moving towards. Then it's why talk
about any of it? Just keep moving. You could keep moving the
goalpost so it's all war. You go back to like Sabra and Chhatilla,
you could say that's a part of the war. You go back to like you
go back to the Palestinians hijacking airplanes, right? Say that's
a part of a like it's it's just stupid >> for aid. >> But
you're suggesting that that it is the policy of the Israeli government
to murder civilians. And that's that is a notion that I reject.
>> You got to like listen man, you got to be like a human
being about this. >> People who are dying in the war, which
to me is a tragedy because war is a >> Do you feel in your
heart that this is what you're what you're saying is right? If
you remove Hamas, >> don't actually think that. >> I
told you what I believe. Don't tell me what I believe. I've told
you what I >> Why would you believe that? >> Because
I because there are people who see the world differently. I know
it's a shock to you, but there are people who see the world differently
for me. >> But why? >> I know that's a shock to you.
>> Like I I it seems a little bit like the >> humanitarian
crisis has deteriorated. >> I don't want to be disrespectful
like >> Well, you you've been at various points. >> In
what capacity? >> You've just been hostile. So, >> in
what capacity? >> It's fine. It's just been a gotcha interview.
Dude, the this is like New Yorker is this New Yorker um like
aggression. This is like how people from NYC get down and try
to fight each other. Just like you've been rude at various points
in what capacity
different points at different points. I don't know what to say.
>> This is why we don't send monkeys to argue for our points.
>> Okay. Nope. Shut the [__] up. That's rude.
That's racist. Disavow. Not funny. Gross.
Gross. Gross. Gross. Uh, also one sub away from another two hours
on the stream, guys, or another $5 donation. >> I think
that uh my conscience is clear, especially as someone that's
lived there and seen it and love people that live there. And
uh this sucks. I really didn't want to do this and I think that
you saw it as gotcha. >> This is what people are talking
about right now. Well, not in not in South Bronx. People are
not talking about Israel. People are talking about >> how
to put food on the table. >> Maybe in your world that's
what people are talking about. In my world, people are struggling.
So yeah, the why if >> Dude, Adam could just keep cooking
them here. Yeah, in my world with my family that has family living
in Israel, we talk about Israel. You have a problem with American
uh Americans talking about Israel, Richie? Is that a Is that
an issue for you, Richie? >> Something in your world. Are
you paying $25 billion? >> We have a seven We have a $7
billion We have a $7 trillion budget in the federal >> Right.
Less than >> So it's not that much money. >> Less
than 1%. So there's a little money went to Israel >> in
the grand scheme of the federal budget. Yes, it's minuscule.
>> I'm sorry, dude. You're bummed. Your consultants told
you not to do it. You >> this I like
Thank you for the Thank you for the gifted sub.
>> Your consultants told you not to do it. They were right.
Okay% your handlers. Little money went to Israel >> in
the grand scheme of the federal budget. Yes, it's min. >> I'm
sorry, dude. You're bummed. Your consultant told you not to do
it. This I like this guy a lot, too. I hate this. This is so
embarrassing. I don't I I don't have anything to hide. I'm willing
to go anywhere. >> No, man. I'm sorry. I I I uh I appreciate
your time. Listen, having this opportunity is for me is a is
a big deal. I don't I don't get to talk to someone in the government
that's that's taking part of these big decisions like this. And
uh I >> Well, only one of 535. So, >> well, I'll
talk to which one is
donkeys.
Donkeys. Dawn demo cracked. Oh
>> Oh.
Well, no. No,
I don't know if I believe you. I don't. He's saying he meant
to put a D, not an M, but I don't believe him. I don't believe
the guy who wrote that. Okay, but thank you, Ben, for clearing
it up. Okay, nice save, Ben. That'll be good enough for the Daily
Wire crowd. All right, they'll believe you. They'll believe you.
You can clean up the living in sewage and bombing things. All
right, if you can clean that one up, you can clean that up. You
can clean that that TTS up for >> Well, only one of 535.
So, >> well, I'll talk to another one. Which one is would
like be Virginia Fox? I don't know. >> Do you ever remember
number? >> I don't have a number. No. >> All right.
I I appreciate I feel like you're mad at me or something. I got
to get a big laugh. >> Uh but look, it is this is it's
like Roth from the Godfather 2. He said, "This is the life we've
chosen." So, >> you know, I know what I signed up for.
>> Is this what happens? This has been a terri I've been
doing a terrible job. I'm rambling about Israel and the being
a Holocaust. It's the most embarrassing stuff to talk about in
public. I feel like everyone, every American >> has a right,
should have a right to be who they are, >> to wear a keepa,
to display a star of David, to be proudly invisibly >> without
fear of harassment or intimidation or violence. >> Well,
that's uh I I believe that would be Adam's opinion, too, unless
I'm >> The freedom to be >> I think he's just saying
that like if you do get harassed over, you know, people's family
members dying, you probably should just go like, you know, I
get it. That's up. Please don't harass me. Please don't make
me feel in fear for my safety. sucks that your family's in in
danger, right? You'd say that >> We are is like fundamental
for all of >> Well, I think that from where I'm sitting,
Israel might be a threat to >> And you know, you have that
view, but others have a different view. >> Why are we still
having this interview? >> This is exhausting. I'm sweating.
>> Dude, he titled he titled the ending walkoff. And Adam's
like, "We shouldn't even be doing this. Why are we even having
this interview?" And the the last section's called Walkoff. I
don't know if he's really walking off if you tell him he should
just go. >> Why are we still having this interview? This
is exhausting. I'm sweating.
I'm just trying to find a button to shake your hand. Dude, I
don't want to [__] do this. >> We could talk
about so much other [__] >> No, I think you
had an agenda. Speak about this. >> I really didn't have
an agenda. I really >> It's your number one. >> It's
not my number one topic. It's just >> It is your It's not
my number one topic. It's not >> Well, I saw I was not
elected on You don't get elected in the South Bronx and >> I'm
not trying to make you feel bad or
I just don't think you know what you're talking about. >> Be
honest. Adam knew exactly what he was doing and this was all
a performance from him. It was a performance but he could be
actually emotionally, you know, invested in that performance,
right? That's not what you're Let's go look at the Hold on. x.com
Richie Torres.
Richie Torres. Let's see what Richie Torres talks about. Let's
just take a quick look. Let's have a Let's have a quick glance.
The Bronx is essential. Okay, I'll say right off the bat, I was
expecting somewhere in the promotional materials to have a star
of David. There isn't one. I think that's interesting. Okay,
I was expecting it. I don't see it. Official We won. This is
pinned.
Alexander Costa, Donald Trump's former labor secretary, not only
entered into a non-prosecution agreement with Jeffrey Epste,
but also help withheld the sweetheart deal from Epstein's victims.
This is about uh Epstein. Epstein, the Bronx, Smithsonian, Trump.
Trump. He's He's shifted, guys. He gets it. He gets it. It can't
all be about Israel.